Yeah. How's that? Is that
it? Is that for real?
I always wondered when I was a little kid,
why do American Indian songs
sound so like, like what is that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then I realize they're high as fuck
cause when you're high as fuck then
it seems like it sounds kind of cool.
Jesus dude. Sounding really cool
right now. Rogan. Yeah, exactly. Yeah.
Yay.
What though?
The rattling sound that you hear Lacey
gentleman is an actual bottle of Alpha
brain.
Oh,
do not.
Well you also hear my fucking laptop
in the background because I'm retarded.
This is,
this is Outbrain.
This is what I take before I do
anything cause I'm an Alpha brain junky.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I take the shit before I do standup.
I'm not lying about this by the way.
I take this before I do any podcasts,
any UFC. I've done you fcs before
without him and I panic a panic.
I got to go with extra red bull and
me and Mike Goldberg make fucking,
we have races to see who can
get to the bathroom first.
Rebel goes right through
you. I said, double stack it.
This is not a red bull type feeling.
If you're wondering what Alpha brain is,
it's essentially nutrients that
enhance your ability, your,
your brain's ability to
produce neurotransmitters.
It's all different nutrients that have
been shown to have a positive effect on
brain function. It is a very
controversial subject. Um, I've,
I've looked at both ends of it. I've
talked to people who think it's a placebo.
I believe that everybody's body
works completely differently.
I know that some people can eat peanuts
and have a great old time and other
people eat them and they're fucking dead.
I don't understand that.
But what I do understand is what
benefits mean and what has been shown to
benefit people and what,
what has a long history of human use.
And that's all the ingredients inside
Alpha brain. To go and check this out,
go to [inaudible] dot com it's o, n, n,
I, t, and all of it is explained to you.
And the way, the only reason why I
would be in business with anybody,
and this is this includes
Tang, which we, you know,
we're in business with sometimes
or audible or you know,
any of the alien where any of the people
that we, we, we talk about on the show,
even that we don't get money from
like h two o or a c two o rather see,
oh yeah, water. Does he give
us any money? Those kinds of,
she bitches a c two oh, coconut water.
It's fucking delicious. They're great.
Grillo's pickles. They're fucking the
most delicious pickles on earth. I, if,
if I tell you it's
because it's true to me.
I believe it 100% there's news. I've
been wrong about shit before. Trust me.
But I'll tell you that too.
If I am wrong,
I'll absolutely fucking telling
you I'm wrong. Alphabet.
I'm not wrong about the fucking dreams
that you have. First of all, that's,
I would take it just for the dreams.
If you'd take it and then go to bed,
you have the most intense graphic dreams.
They're intense and they're,
they're very lucid man. And I don't know
what it is, but it's not bad for you.
That's all you have to worry.
It's all just nutrients.
There's nothing crazy in there.
There's no pharmaceutical
drugs is nothing to addictive.
Can tell you about a story
about one of the dreams.
I gave something to my Russian housekeeper
and she took them and she went back
to a lot via 1965 and spoke to her
grandfather. Whoa. In the dream,
the lucid dream.
And she came back the next day and she's
like playing with the fuck Jesus Christ.
He's lucid. Dreams are no joke. They don't
know. They don't always happen though.
I've taken it before and had nothing.
I've had no dreams. Um, I don't,
I don't understand the
process behind her dream.
It was so intense that you inside your
dream found out a way to delete it so you
won't remember it, baby.
Yeah. Well that's, you know,
that's the mechanism
behind dimethyltryptamine.
The mechanism behind dimethyltryptamine
is the same mechanism behind a dreams,
which is really weird. How, you know, how
you can wake up and you're like, fuck,
what a dream I had, man.
We were on roller skates,
we were running from Godzilla and
it was my cousin who I grew up with,
but I haven't seen him since I was
13 he's like, why didn't you call me?
And I felt fucking guilty.
Meanwhile Godzilla's chasing
us and you could remember it.
But then if I came up to you like
a half an hour later and I said,
tell me what that dream again. You'd be
like, well fucking train mas it again.
Shit. What happened? Hate. Fuck. It's
weird. It's like your brain erases it.
It's like whatever it is is based on
something that the brain is already really
good at getting rid of.
And that DMT DMT,
which is a crazy psychedelic drug that
your brain makes. And it's also, you know,
available in plant form.
But the idea is that when you are,
you're dreaming intense dreams at what's
going on is your brain is producing
dimethyltryptamine,
your brain is producing this hallucinogen
and nobody really understands what
it's about. And some people
actually believe that, you know,
there's an old term called sleep
on it. You know, if you have,
you have something that's bothering you,
sleep on it,
and maybe you come up with a
good decision in the morning.
A lot of the reasons for that term is
because you really do think about things
that are troubling you and while you're
sleeping and if you are tripping,
if that is what's happening
when you're sleeping,
if we're all growing through a DMT trip,
that is a race by the time we wake up,
which is a distinct
possibility considering the
weirdness of dreams and what,
what are they, the ones that seem
really real, what are, what are these,
these are obviously hallucinations,
like really intense hallucinations but
in a much more controlled form then like
say a DMT state. Well it could just be,
it's a low level of DMT experiences,
certain um,
eastern religions which believe that the
life we're living now is actually just
the dream at your highest self is having,
which I find very interesting.
It's just as likely as being alive,
being alive. It's pretty fucking bizarre.
Being able to measure things so you're
fucking eyeballs and figure out where
things are. All of that is,
it's weird as shit, man.
Being a human is weird as shit is
fucking crazy. Dreams are weird.
It's weird that you shut off every night.
It's weird to for eight hours.
We just accept that we're going to
just normal and you look forward to it.
Everybody's scared to die. No one's scared
to take naps. Just fucking shut. Right.
I used to go to sleep as a kid. I'd
be like, Oh shit. Here it comes.
I don't know why Alpha brain gives you
a of, so you can send me with tenure
with us, but it does. It gives
you crazy fucking dreams.
Shroom tech support is another
great product from on it.
It's my favorite product as far
as like a athletic performance.
It's based on a quarter steps.
Mushroom,
plenty of data out there after
interested in googling it. Um,
the quarter zips mushroom is also the
same mushroom that makes fucking ants that
like makes them zombies and
makes their heads explode.
Different strain of different
strain folks. It comes out.
You don't have to worry about
that. You ever seen that? Yeah.
There's a branch of the quarter steps
mushrooms that infects these uh, ants.
Fascinating shit man. And it turns
a turns. The ants and the like,
these Zombie ants and the other ants have
to get the body when these things die
and get them whey the fuck away from
the ant hill because they explode out
spores, which they affect all these
other ants. What are you saying?
Welcome to the call for. Okay, listen,
I'm not saying that it's not the same.
It's not the same thing.
Imagine if that's how we're doing.
Your honor would say they're
doing mine control in the form
mushroom mind control.
It's not that folks.
That's what it was, man
motivators. Aubrey brands,
29 year old dude had it all figured out.
We're going to have fucking for
flashlights in the future. His hands.
Listen folks, I don't listen
to that guy. He's crazy.
But we also have kettle bells,
which are recently in and battle ropes.
That's all. Everything we sell is
the highest quality shit possible.
You can't get any better.
And we tried to sell it to you as cheap
as possible and make the deal as easy as
possible.
With all the nutritional supplements.
There's a 100% money back
guarantee in the first 30 pills.
You don't have to send them back
and just say this stuff socks,
because nobody wants to rip you off and
we're only selling you the best shit and
I guarantee you if you start using it,
you're going to appreciate the effects
of it and you're gonna or you're some
fucking weird or the candy
peanuts. I don't know. I
don't know what your deal man.
Go to [inaudible] dot com use the code
name Brogan and you'll save yourself 10%
off the supplements and you will save
nothing off battle ropes and kettlebells
cause them shits is expensive and don't
use the code name London real on this
show. Wait for our show. Yeah, if
you use the code named Lyndon Real,
do you get something?
You get like 10% of us and
then Joe offsets in the parking lot later
going off through the words that keep
on code cock block. It is a
coupon code, cock block exercise.
It would be if we were all like go on
some sort of a percentage of sales basis.
That's why you would want to use the
word olive garden. Fuck you. Get,
they charge you more. They say that
son of a bitch charge him double.
We were told we were told to olive
garden before Brian did new percent you,
they charge you more. Do
you, can I get a call?
I'll keep on code that charges
$10 more on your order,
but it just donates the death squad.
That would be hilarious. Yeah.
That is the other thing. We're
sponsored by desk squad. Dot.
TV is Brian's site or Brian makes
these ridiculous cat tee shirts that,
I see it all my shows now
that that is a,
that those are all his designs and the
money goes to Brian to support his death
squad podcast network and you're like,
what the fuck is a desk squad?
It's a very vague in strange,
strange topic,
but we got Kevin Tomorrow. Yes,
Kevin prayer come a part of it.
The desk that squad is, it's just a
nickname that was given to us a long,
long time ago and it's now sort of
branched out into Brian's podcasts and,
and it's still like,
it's a family, you know,
that's what really desk what represents
to all of us. You know, when we,
when we talk about if we put death squad
under a post and it's Joey is and Ari
and Brian and Dunkin are all on a
show together, you know, that's,
that's what we call it desk.
While here it's family.
It's just like the hall of Jesus Christ.
It's like subliminal the motherfucker.
He entered into my mind with an
olive garden commercial olive garden,
will you please pay this fuck olive
garden? What do we, what do we have to do?
And he's gotten them saying it.
Brody Stevens is recommending the olive
garden on the fucking Chelsea handler's
show you sons of bitches get off
your ass and sponsor this kid.
He's the number one olive garden.
Support it in the country. Essentially.
I don't understand it,
but I also don't understand that just
for men commercial where the fucking baby
has a beard and drives a car. I don't
understand that. There's a lot of shit.
I don't understand. Have you seen that
commercial? We'll talk about that. Listen,
you know how it was in London. London
real is here. Strap the fuck in.
We're fixing to get shit. Pop and
desk. Squad. Dot TV for the tee shirts.
Stickers represent a desk squad all over
the country that you guys were there in
North Carolina and I saw you in Toronto.
All you fucking freaks. Alright.
Cue The music.
Sun Experience.
Train by day.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Gentlemen,
welcome. Welcome. Thank you to be,
it's awesome to be so good to
have you guys here. Um, uh, I, uh,
saw you guys on youtube a while back.
Uh, I don't remember what the f I just,
just say that the gentleman,
Brian and nick, who's Brian
who's name, I'm Brian Rose
from London real. These guys are, uh,
one of the coolest up and coming podcast
that I've had a chance to listen to and
uh, really, uh, is fucking right up our
alley. The stuff you guys talk about,
the people that you have on, you know,
you had shock filet on, you had uh,
you had Graham Hancock on fresco.
You mean, did I say, I'm sorry,
which one is Jack Valet?
No frescoes in 96 year old frescoes.
The Venus project and a project
guy. Yeah, sorry, Mr. Shock. Uh,
but you've had a, you know,
you had Graham Hancock on,
you guys have had some just right up
our alley guests. It's really, uh, it's,
it's beautiful to see that there's more
out there that there's people that are
doing this in London. You know, there's
people that are doing this in Toronto.
I ran into a lot of people in Toronto
that have podcasts and it's essentially,
it's all the same thing. It's like, you
know, you get together and you go, women,
I would like to talk about some shit
that I don't see talked about in the
mainstream news.
Like there's all this nonsense in the
news about celebrities or about parts of
the world that really don't even have
anything to do with our day to day lives,
but there's all these other weird subjects
that aren't getting covered. You know,
there's so much, it's fascinating
things about like what, wait, what?
What's going on with the
psychedelics? Like what is this? What?
What are they here for? What's
this all about? Because this,
can this be a debate for intelligent
people to sit down and talk or does it
immediately get derided and,
and, and reduced to some
silliness to some, oh yeah.
What were you going to take a loosen a
Jones? Yeah. Why don't you just fucking,
why don't you get up in the morning and
put a tie on like a gentlemen, you know,
to Hancock about that. As soon as
I mentioned I Wasco or anything,
everyone's eyes just glaze
over and they're like, oh,
you're one of those guys.
Yeah.
They think you're a crazy person.
If you want to talk about
altered states of consciousness,
you're a crazy person in California too.
Yeah. Well, it's a little better here.
It's a little better here. Um, this is
the most progressive spot in the country,
I think as far as like the ideas of,
I have a feeling about
humans in America and the,
it's not that there's not
amazing people on the east coast.
There's amazing people all throughout
the country, but I think there's a,
there's a prevailing attitude of the,
the region.
Like people always talk about
liberals in California. Well,
the reason why is because like in the
east coast is where all the people first
landed, right? That's where all
the people from Europe are like,
Fuck Europe or so done. There's a
new spot. They can't fuck with you.
We're going to make our own laws.
And that got all crazy and conti and
people just decided to keep going.
And a lot of people kept going
and they just kept going.
They eventually on fucking horses with
wooden wheels got all the way to the
other side and we're like, fuck, we can't
go any further. All right, let's stop.
People complain when the transatlantic
flight is delayed by 30 minutes.
And then it was what would the
ancestors went through, right? Yeah.
They had to eat each other.
Man Eat each other and the milestone
with eight each other. That sound,
that's no joke,
man.
It was a scary time for human beings and
I think there was a lot of times where,
you know,
people would start out and not make it.
They would try and a scary time
for human beings though, Joe,
and this is a scary game. We're
all playing, right? It is.
It's the same scary game we were
playing when I was in high school,
when I was in high school, was
about the Soviets. It was always,
you were talking about that
recently. People Forget. I mean,
I used to go to sleep at
night, really worried about
nuclear war. How old are you?
I'm 41 you ever see that movie?
The day after it was on,
I was like 10 or 12 it was his whole
television movie about basically a nuclear
war and the end of it, I mean,
I stood up. I was up for days.
I don't remember that one in particular,
but I bet I saw it.
I've seen so many of them.
I've seen so many apocalyptic mad max
type movies where the, for some reason,
you know, I am legend type
shit goes down and we just,
you think America needs an enemy.
Like do we need someone to kind of always
be the bad guy? Well, we're not real.
So when you say it, does America need
an enemy? America's not even real. It's,
there's just a bunch of humans and they
did decide to call it American act as a
group, but it's pretty obvious at this
point that it's, that's not real. It's us.
That's real.
It's humans and he might as well be
you guys when you hear your Americans,
it's like, what? What is America? It's
just a fucking spot. It's just a spot.
And the idea that this spot
acts as one unit and, and,
and we should all go along
with what the spots doing.
That's fucking completely ridiculous
because we don't get a say it's,
and what they're doing is
completely contrary to what
most of the people in this
country would want to get done.
So what we have is like a fake country
and we have a really a dictatorship.
That's run by money and it's
just run with a loose grip.
It's not run with a dog
collar around your neck,
so you constantly feel oppressed.
It's run with a loose grip of corruption.
It's a loose grip of corruption and
entanglement where there's no way to get
into the system where a
guy like Gary Johnson,
who's the only one left running for
president who makes any fucking sense.
The Libertarian candidate can't even
get into the debates because they won't
treat them seriously because
the media is really fake.
The media is really bought and
sold and it's a news program.
It's a news program where they pick
and choose what aspects of the news,
what angle of the news instead of giving
you all the information and anything
that has anything to do with criticizing
America or anything that shows American
a bad light is all got to
be reviewed before it's put
on air. It shows, you know,
while I was watching you while
you were giving that speech,
I just really felt that you
really want people to wake up.
You rarely odd tarnation wake up to,
they can't operate like this.
They don't have to. The news
doesn't have to operate like this.
The government doesn't
have to operate like this.
The corporations don't
No one's saying you can't do business.
What we're saying is business doesn't
mean you have to fucking rob people.
Business doesn't mean you have to use
lobbyists to influence policy so that you
can pollute rivers.
Business doesn't mean that you can
store nuclear waste in the middle of the
fucking desert because you
don't know how to get rid of it.
You're not supposed to do any of that
stuff until you know how to get rid of it.
Don't make it.
You know,
we should really probably shouldn't
even be on fucking nuclear power because
we've had several major incidents
over the past 100 years.
100 years ain't shit when it comes to how
long the fucking earth is and how long
radioactive material lasts.
So if you're having nuclear,
if they've put together these power
plants that if something goes wrong,
that spot is poison for 100,000 years.
You cannot live there anymore. And then
even after a hundred thousand years,
who's going to be that first
of fucking move back there?
If we've keep an any sort of
accurate records whatsoever,
who the fuck is going to be the first
person to move back to where there was a
nuclear disaster and power
plants imploded? No one,
no one's going to do that.
So that spots ruined essentially
for longer than humans
have is existed. That's,
that's how long we've ruined Chernobyl.
That's how long we've ruined Fukushima.
We're ruining the spots. I, and it's,
there's a lot of power plants, man,
hundreds of them all over the place and
they could all equal a spot where one
day you can't go anywhere near them.
We're,
we're assuming we're going to be able
to keep the power on indefinitely and
Cooley's fucking things off. That's
why they've built them. Yeah.
But it's in human nature to only change
our behavior when something really bad
happens. It's just the way it is.
Right. What's fascinating, it's a,
it's just an aspect of denial, you know,
it's in, that's how corporations work.
The reason what corporations are able
to get away with the shit they do bribe
politicians and and and,
and influence,
literally wore and murder is because
they act as a group that's just trying to
get zeroes and ones,
they're just trying to get money so they
don't look at things in terms of like
their moral value.
They look,
they look at things in terms of
is this good for our stockholders?
Is this good for our business? Can we
make a profit here? Can we get over there?
And when you have
companies where you know,
you get a guy like Dick Cheney who's
the fucking head of a company called
Halliburton that fix his shit up after
it gets blown up and then this guy
becomes the vice president and just starts
blowing shit up and then giving these
contracts with the company
that he used to run.
That is one of the craziest things
that's ever happened in front of human
beings.
W there was,
it was essentially a jacking on
television live publicly and government
sanctioned where they jacked
a whole country and jack
the American people to and
made us give money to these corporations
that would fix shit that we blow up and
even build shit that's not necessary.
Have you talked to people
that are over there?
They'll tell you that they just have
like a certain amount of money they're
supposed to spend and they have a certain
amount of projects that they can build
a desalinization plant that people like,
we don't fucking need this.
Like we're building it. You know you
need it, you want it. It doesn't matter.
We were building a desalinization plant
cause we've got the contract for it and
there's just billions of dollars is
going over their billions and billions.
Neil degrasse Tyson had a speech where
he was talking about that we have the
capability now we have the knowledge and
the knowhow to build a telescope that
literally can go back and look
at the beginnings of time.
Like we can build a telescope that
is just infinitely more powerful than
anything that exists today would cost
about $10 million, $10 billion to,
you know,
it sounds like an incredible amount of
money until you find out how much money
to spend in Iraq. And they spent 10
million billion dollars every few days.
I was just constant of of species must
have a really a really negative comma
because we have so much potential,
but we just seem to channel it in
the wrong direction. And maybe,
maybe it's not us. Maybe it's just
a comma that we're burning through.
We have to go through all this shit.
It's not us, it's just the look.
The business of running
countries has not changed.
Although the access to
information has changed radically.
So the understanding of what a country
really is, it's changed radically.
But the business of running countries
has not changed to same thing that they
did during the Roman
empire they're doing today.
They're just doing it through
a loose series of guidelines.
But it's really clear that they're
robbing country's resources,
controlling people's militaries,
attacking people mercilessly,
putting fear and terror.
And you want to talk about Orwellian,
we have fucking robots that we operate
with remote control from the other side
of the planet that shoot missiles from
the sky that kill people like that is
bananas. The fact that that's one
of the major ways that we rocket.
In 2012 we literally sent fucking Darth
Vader spaceships that shoot rockets from
the sky. That is the, that's insane.
Do you ever get concerned that you might
have or you might face repercussions
from the US government one way or another
for the views you're promoting their
show? Well, no, because I just, it's
everything that I'm saying is all obvious.
It's all right out there in the open.
It's not,
I mean like if you want to
look at the Halliburton thing,
it's not like that fucking Rogan.
He gave up the goods on Halliburton.
Everybody knows that Halliburton has
a completely corrupt, the, the, the,
the relationship that Halliburton to
the United States is completely corrupt.
Just by virtue of the fact that they
got no bid contracts, these enormous,
enormous contracts. Like that's not
the taxpayer is being looked after.
That's not the government being frugal
or being conservative with money.
That's a relationship between someone
who influenced either directly with money
or indirectly by getting their
former CEO to run the country.
I think the idea of a
corporation has a good thing.
I just think we need to regulate the
fuck out of him. It they have to,
they have to have a good mind.
I mean from a just a limited
liability corporate standpoint.
I mean you do believe that there is a
reason for them because otherwise if you
couldn't,
she couldn't invest in on it and then
otherwise they might come and take your
car away. I think it's unlimited
lives. I think. I believe,
I believe in paying taxes. I pay my
taxes. I never cheat on my taxes.
I pay a lot of money in
taxes. I pay, I believe in,
I believe in state taxes too. I mean, I
think I pay state taxes in California.
I know a lot of people that move to
Nevada strictly because they don't have to
pay state taxes and stuff.
I don't mind paying for things.
I don't mind government.
I think it all can be done correctly
and but it's all going to be done.
It sounds Corny as fuck,
but it's all going to be done with love.
It can't be done with fear and
it's all being done with fear.
The whole way the world is being
done is being done with fear and it's
everybody's like, fuck
you, I'm going to Nuku.
If there were people that would be
the most ridiculous people ever.
If I ran an Israel with people,
you'd want to kill the both of them.
You'd be like, well, you to
just shut the fuck up. My God.
You bickering cunts. You next door
neighbors who just, you're a fucking baby.
You're a baby.
This one asshole has a cartoon bomb he's
using in a UN speech to show when it
gets to here,
that's one we're in trouble like I,
it's a bomb like showing
Iran's nuclear capabilities.
If you've seen this now is this, let's
pull this up. Brian's doing Netanyahu.
That mother fucker, that's silly
bitch Netanyahu, who's the the,
what does the prime minister of Israel.
He's showing like when
we have to attack Iran,
he's got this nuclear
bomb and it's like get
to a certain point and that's when you
got to attack. They're just, I mean,
they're insecure over there and they're
like pawns in a little chess game that
had all the big powers are
playing in the same zero Yahoo,
Yahoo, Yahoo. Yeah.
Netanyahu bomb cartoon joint
Israeli Palestinian podcast.
I think it would just need him talk.
It's, yeah, that's, that's the,
that's the, the, the conflict
to end all conflicts.
That's the conflict that's
going been going on forever.
It's like it's never going to end that
whole Middle Eastern coffee. Look at that.
Look at that picture. Okay. That's,
is that the most ridiculous shit ever?
He's like, well, this is it.
When I'm in a job said it's childish
and I agree with them in a job.
How about that dude who
says no Iranian gaze?
He doesn't believe in gay
marriage. She's, I believe,
who knows what the Holocaust gyre
is really said. Is he a holocaust?
Jesus Christ.
Meanwhile,
I believe in him when it's his
taste tasting cartoons is excellent.
At least you're honest. It just,
it seems like, you know, so
if, if, if,
if corporations and governments
all sort of have this diffusion of
responsibility and even
though we're in America,
all the things that go on
that we don't agree with,
like drone attacks and all
the shit, you know, it all,
it becomes a matter of how much of
an impact does that have on the rack,
the whole rest of the population.
And if it only has a minor impact
on the rest of the population,
a lot of times he can get away with it.
And that's the situation that we're
in right now. We know that too.
In order to change things,
who would require a major overhaul and
it would be really difficult for a lot of
people.
I mean,
the government is comprised
of a huge amount of,
of human beings.
There's a lot of people that
essentially are completely unnecessary.
If we had a real Justin true government,
they're really not necessarily,
I don't really believe in conspiracies.
I think it's just people have these
positions where they had these great jobs
and they're collecting money as a
contractor. Halliburton and whites.
Why change things? Yeah, there's a lot
of that, but there's also conspiring.
We know they conspired with Enron
and essentially Halliburton was,
they were allowed to conspire
Halliburton's clear conspiracy.
But we also know a lot about
government conspiracy from the past.
That's not just like ideas and thoughts,
but stuff that actually has
been proven to have happened.
Like the Gulf of Tonkin. They'll,
they'll, you know, the, the,
the idea that they got us into a war
in Vietnam with like a fake story.
They've got the operation
Northwoods operation dirty trick,
which is where they were going to blow
John Glenn was going to be the first
person into orbit and if anything happened
to his, his space shuttle, his, uh,
his rocket,
they were going to blame it on.
The Cubans were going to
blow up like some fucking,
it was a reason to attack Cuba. We
were like, look, it's a win win.
If John Glenn makes it, he's the
first guy in space, you know,
if it doesn't make it, we blame it
on, the Cubans would go fuck him up.
And that was, that was the plan.
And this is not a conspiracy.
This is like this is written document.
Do you think the government
needs some secrecy?
Otherwise there's no diplomacy.
I mean you can't have a policy but it
means Obama can announced the night before
he's going to go in and and
you know assassinate and
that has to be some kind of,
I don't, first of all, I don't
believe they did really loud.
No Dude's good debt.
I've talked about people.
If I had to say,
I would probably say that more than
anything else that Joe blow is fishing.
I've talked to dudes who are in special
forces type jobs and they were like,
that guy's been dead forever.
They're like those guys.
But I dunno what the fuck happened.
And dudes were laughing about it.
Like was tell him, write that story. Nope,
didn't sound right to anybody
in any other country either.
Because you hear about that guy that wrote
that book that's like a national best
seller that he was one of the guys.
His story differs from the government
versus he said it would be like if it was
really weird,
his beard was completely black.
When they came in and like there
was no gray hairs and stuff.
Like would he be really just for
meaning his beard? Well, he might,
Brendan Walsh does.
I think it looks sexy as fuck on Brendan.
I would say I would support it. And
why not do you don't do it? Who Cares?
You know? Uh, but, uh, I don't,
who cares? I don't care if they,
I don't think, you know,
the whole reason why, oh,
that guy existed is because we
do it the only way a guy like,
uh,
Osama bin Ladin or any of these radical
guys ever exists is there's gotta be
some great empire to oppose and it's not
a great empire of altruism is trying to
help people all over the world and trying
to enhance the lives of people and,
and clean up their areas
and make money in, in,
in helping countries instead of making
money and just robbing their resources
and then taking out their military, taking
out their collapse, it will collapse.
That's the problem. We don't have to
have an empire. See, that's the problem.
They're all empires do collapse
because they're run by cons.
You can't run an empire, not be a con.
Well, we not, we need is civilization.
We don't need an empire anymore. All
these, these, these organizations,
they're not,
they're not necessary.
What we need to figure out is how natural
resources can be distributed equally
to all nations.
And that sounds fucked up.
But that's reality is otherwise everyone's
just going to go where the resources
are and they're going to argue
about this a lot. I mean, I think,
I'd like to believe that that's the case,
that we could have a free society of a
fairer society. But, um, I think Brian,
you believe that like human nature just,
it's never going to happen, right? I mean,
I have a lot of thoughts
about human nature. I think
humans are inherently lazy.
And if we had like a socialist system,
a lot of people wouldn't do anything.
So I think capitalism doesn't
motivate people to a certain extent.
Of course it can go a little too far.
Certainly Kenton's corporation start
acting in their own interest and they
become really big and it certainly
is a great motivating factor.
I believe you should be rewarded
for your efforts. I mean,
I believe that in many of the
ideas that go behind capitalism,
where I think we fuck up is
with shit like the stock market,
things that can be
manipulated where you can on.
I got to talk to you about derivatives.
I got to drop some time attempts.
You all right. So, um, I actually
spent some time in Boston.
I spent four years at Mit, I think
around the same time you were there. Oh,
I don't know if I will.
I don't want too many comedy clubs when
I was there and was fucking awesome town
if it wasn't so cold. Especially
Cambridge. What a great place.
Right across from the necco wafer
factory on two. So three masses.
So you'd worked in,
do you understand the riveter?
Which I got a mechanical
engineering degree,
but I went straight to Wall Street
afterwards and worked in banking.
And then for the last 10 years I worked
in London and the credit derivative
industry, but worst of all derivatives.
So what is it? It's your gambling.
Ghanaians and driven as I was.
I was thinking about how I could talk
about this and I hear you talk about it
all the time.
So I figure I must be frustrating.
Like this room [inaudible] I have
friends that'll talk about Jujitsu,
you know like coy hoists. Gracie,
when he'd do just grab them,
we're just reach over and grab
the neck. I'm like no, he did it.
And it could be worse.
It could have friends.
You can have friends that took about
comfort ride, right? Oh No, I had a guy,
this is the worst shot out I
could ever give anyone. But
he said to me when he popped up with a
chat when he was like tried to talk to
Joe about cooking food cause I think yes,
some negative ideas and I was like,
look dude, I don't really believe
in [inaudible] through myself,
so it's going to be tough for me
to convince him. We just, you know,
it's not that Kung Fu doesn't work,
it's just,
it's definitely not the best way to go.
It's that simple.
There's a lot of stuff that works, you
know, if you back for someone in the face,
I mean it, it, it's
not going to feel good.
It's not gonna feel good to
get back fist in the face,
but it's not as good as you
fucking overhand, right. Somebody,
it's just not qualifiers. It's, it's
not that it doesn't work, it's just,
it doesn't work on the right people.
You know,
you can probably knock out an 86 year
old grandmother with the white crane
dancing tiger technique, but tried on an
MMA fighter. It's not going to happen.
Well,
it's also the way they practice it a lot,
the way a lot of people are practicing it.
I'm like, oh my God. Like you're, you're,
you're, you're being silly.
It's like you're strong,
a punch and then you're pretending
that if you threw that punch,
what I would do is that what you step
right here and then I would attack your
organs like this with a claw motion. We
would, come on, we just had, I'm Roger,
could I do that? That guy's got a
punch you again and again and again.
He's going to kick you in the Dick.
It's going to be a lot of shit happening.
You're not gonna have time to get
off that claw claw to the liver.
We just had Roger Gracie in the studio
on Friday and he was talking about,
we were rubbishing off Kung Fu and karate,
something bad.
We're going to get some hate.
But he was talking about the Kata and
have you get good at the cocktail.
You get your belt. And he was like, but
in Jujitsu you spa and you haven't test,
you can put a choke on someone,
but what about if he doesn't
want you to put it on?
And he just was kind of breaking down
some of the core differences. Yeah,
there's a big difference. I have a black
belt in taekwondo as well in taekwondo.
There was guys that were black
belts that weren't that good.
They just weren't that good.
They had been around a long time.
They'd take their forms and they,
they did okay and sparring,
but the reality is they
weren't really black belts.
They'd never reached that expert level.
Like they could get mugged.
Someone can kick their ass like they
really weren't adept at fighting.
Do you know what I find
is very interesting Joe,
which you might appreciate these.
If you look at some of those
more ridiculous martial arts. Um,
you see a guy like 45 or 55, you see
digital guy at that age, he stopped,
he still rolls. He's like
he's in shape, you know,
but you see one of these
guys and without fail,
every single 45 year old plus traditional
martial artist is the guy who's got
like a slouch and a beer belly and you
can see he hasn't done a pushup for like
15 years. You know what I mean? Yeah.
Those like Uci Rue guys and
the weirdest thing poisons.
They want to be called by some weird title
as well. You said it was in the face.
He pulled up like some
weapons on Facebook.
There are any tall guy with a backpack
and you're like, look at his face.
It's not a Jujitsu black cause he didn't
have the lines on his face like all
those hard because he doesn't take
himself. He just hides behind,
like he gets his belt where it gets a
certificate and he says, okay, that's me.
I'm this grand master.
And then all the little students bow to
him because I think he's got mystical
powers, but at the end of
the day he's not progressing.
He's not progressing in his art
and just makes my blood boil man.
For those who don't know what nick is,
her Jujitsu black belt. Yeah, there's,
that's what Jujitsu is all about,
exposing reality and there's a lot of
martial arts that are about putting on a
show. It's really kind of
completely contrary to Jujitsu.
It's why in taekwondo had a big impact
on me as a child because in doing
something that was difficult in taekwondo,
it was like the first character forming
thing that I did as as a person.
But there's a lot of cult aspects to it.
You know,
the bowing and the calling, the,
you know, the instructor sir,
and always bowing to them.
They were just like this.
None of that shit's in Jujitsu. The
respect is all like real, legitimate,
natural, friendly respect.
Like John John Machado.
I have a black president and John
Jack as well. And John Jack is,
he's not just like a great Jujitsu coach.
He's like everyone's friend.
He's like a really nice guy.
So he's very informal,
but it's no one ever like disrespects
him or no one ever takes advantage of
that, that friendliness
and thinks that you know,
that they would be a better fighter than
him or they can kick his ass sparring
or something like that. Yeah. But karate
guys will always have to put on not,
and I don't want, I don't
want to say always because
a lot of, um, it's just, uh,
it's, it's done correctly and it is a
discipline and it's all about, you know,
maintaining, you know, the, the,
the, the, the sort of, uh, the, the,
the mindset of the Zen
martial arts practitioner.
There's a lot of people
that are legit about it,
but there's also a lot of people that
they just want to put up a fucking dog and
pony show so that you don't challenge
them and test them and then they develop a
fucking job. I got a great story for
you. We'll get back to derivatives.
Don't worry,
I'll leave it at that.
So when I first started grappling and
Cape Town, it was right before the,
just off the first year I've seen it
was just starting to be understood about
functional martial arts. And um, if you're
the guys at the club where I trained,
they were, they were going
around, they just wanted to learn.
So they going to every martial
arts club they could go,
they could find and just just testing
the instructor and seeing what they could
learn from him.
That's what they get to Ninjitsu
school.
And um,
is that, by the way, what is Ninja
too? It's what I want him to learn.
When I was a kid and I looked
at martial arts magazines,
I was trying to pick out martial arts
to learn before I practice anything.
I was like, it'd be pretty good
to be an engine. I just alcohol.
But I needed something where
you could get a black belt.
That's one of the reasons I wanted karate
first. I wanted to get a black buddy.
Get it.
You don't even know who's the best ones
and they all dress the same I need about
Matt.
So, um, so they get to this
Ninjitsu school and they say
to the guy, you know, we'd,
we'd, um, we'd like to spar with,
you'd like to see your
system and what you can do.
So you said you will wait until after
the class. And so they were like, okay.
They stuck around and watch
them walk on their hands,
whatever it is you do and you do to class.
And then at the end of the class,
the instructor said, he said,
students, we have a challenge.
And what he did is he
took out a blind fold.
You Walk to the center of the Mat
and he knelt down, crossed his arm,
we'll put the blindfold on Christ his
arms and then said to them, my buddy,
he said, attack me. I sweat.
I couldn't make this up
again though.
For my buddy looked around the room
looking for a camera. He was like,
this has gotta be like some kind of joke.
And then he just kind of ran rod to
the back of him and put on a rear naked
choke and this guy like squealed and
didn't know what was going on and
eventually like the guy let him go.
And that was,
that was the end of
Ninjitsu for our training.
Yes. Well it was really nice about it
cause he could have just punted him in the
face.
It's nice that he had kick fucking
shogun style 2004 no it's dead.
He decided to choke him and that's a very
nice guy cause he couldn't just run up
and just need the fuck out of his face.
Or what was your modem right?
Yeah he's silly. Mitch what do you do
at attack me? Oh my God, you're crazy.
There's a lot of dudes
who got mad at me online.
A lot of these black dudes that do Kung
Fu in New York cause there's like a
whole culture like from the warriors
that kind of there. But those guys fit.
Most of it's fake Kung Fu.
When I say fake Kung Fu,
it's like a lot of their doing.
They're making shit up. Like,
what if you did like this? Oh
man, you can't do like that.
Look at how much you've
got exposed like this area.
I'm attacking your knee here silent
like you got, you got problems here.
I've got a tiger cloth
to the side of your neck.
Your whole side of your neck is wide open.
Like they talk to them completely.
I like watching. I laughed
my ass off at him. Look,
these guys want to believe that they're
real martial artists and they're really
mad at me like, and the
guy was like, come on son.
You tell me if I hit you in the facial,
the monkey pod, they wouldn't hurt. Yeah,
yeah.
If you,
if I let you hit me in the face of the
monkey part would probably be hurt.
But the crazy, that's not what I'm
saying here. What I'm saying is you're,
you're practicing some nonsense kid.
All right.
But we all have aspects of our life
in which we're deluding ourselves.
You know what I mean? Just probably
kind of identify them like, oh,
for them it's martial arts. For
us. It may be you, I don't know,
relationships or whatever.
Yeah.
People love to dilute themselves.
It's way easier than facing
the insignificance of
your reality in this crazy
picture of the whole unit.
It's a mechanism for
the brain.
The ego's therefore to give you a
reason to stay alive until you can get
enlightened enough that you no longer
need the ego to appreciate this existence,
but the ego is there to keep you alive.
You're super special when
you're a fucking a 10 year old,
you know your ego sense. That
makes so much sense. It's just a,
it's an engine to push you forward and
then from there it's all about getting
enlightened to the point.
We no longer need the ego,
the ego to enjoy the existence, but that
doesn't happen in the way that joy does.
So you just, you can do it. I did it.
I mean, I'm not perfect, but I'm, I'm,
I'm certainly way more evolved than
I was when I was a younger person,
but what was that? Through training
or through psychedelics or both?
All of the above. Jujitsu
for sure. Helped Jujitsu,
how I'm been doing Jujitsu since
[inaudible] 96 and I think just getting
constantly fucking strangled and going
at it until your heart's going to explode
in your chest and you're trying
not to tap. But you know,
you got to realize you've got to tap
and then you've got to go again because
there's still four minutes left in the
round and you're fucking, you know,
you're going out and you develop these
intense relationships with people because
you understand their character.
You know, you see dudes that break,
you see dudes that will never break.
You know,
guys that are so tough to tap and the,
and you know guys who are above monster
out of the gate but then they run out of
gas. You know, that's me.
No, that's even one level up.
It's like I'm in Jiu Jitsu
instructor and then, um,
I dunno if all digits instructors have it.
I'd love to hear some
from some of the others.
But you know when all your students are
watching and it's like that young tough
20 year old kid and he's the
top purple belt and you're like,
and you're tired and you've got to
carrying an injury or something, you know,
you got to put it on the line of these
buckets aren't going to respect you
anymore. It's true. It's difficult.
Have An,
you know what the reality is,
there's a lot of instructors out there
with Marcello Garcia comes to their
school, they're going to
get tapped so they have to,
they have to figure out what to do here.
Do I just let everybody know? Yeah,
Marcella can tap me and this is how watch
me get treated like a baby. You know?
I mean,
a lot of people have a real issue with
that and then there's a lot of dudes that
say, you know, okay,
now I'm an instructor.
Like I have to make sure I'm lifting
weights. You know, I have to,
I have to be bigger and stronger. Like
Eddie Bravo talks about that. Like, he's,
he fights for his life when he's in,
in those classes because Eddie's
at such a high level right now,
especially his guard. His guard is fucking
so nasty. I rolled with a lot of dudes,
but he's one of the few guys,
him and Danny,
then one of the few guys that consistently
catch me from their guard and the,
that's how fucking hard to
catch someone from the chairman.
I got a role with you. Yeah, seriously
do. Maybe Thursday, Thursday. Cool.
Um, but uh, yeah, come to 10th
planet. I loved how you guys. Um,
I think that, uh, when you, when you
do that on a regular basis and you tap,
you tap people,
you get tapped you to strain.
Yuh Yuh Yuh Yuh Yuh Yuh blow through
all the energy that you have in,
in a, in a, in an endeavor,
especially one that's so primal.
Jujutsu so life, death, you know,
even though you can do it and no one
gets hurt, it's the craziest thing, man.
You don't have this, this
theory, that Jitsu. Um,
I reckon you would know more about someone
after a 10 minute Jujitsu match than
a 10 minute conversation,
10 hour conversation character
be 10 fucking years. You know,
there's certain dudes where you tap
them once and then they're done.
You own them. You could just run right
through them. Even if they're not tired,
they just start giving stuff up.
You know, you see it, you see like,
and you're like, come on man, pull
your arm back. You know, put your arm,
Tuck yourself, you've got to
protect yourself is get that leg,
that leg and you'll start walking
through it. You don't want them to break.
You want them to like to
build up and you know,
you want them to like offer
legitimate resistance.
And that's what sparring supposed to be
about. That happened to me in Brazil.
I went down as a white belt and I was
training Gracie Baha and like all week I
was getting my ass tapped out as a white
belt and then Friday was no gay day and
I showed up obviously with no bell.
And I started rolling with this one dude
and I tapped him like six times and I
think he just didn't know who I was.
And after that first time,
after that first happy it was
over. Yeah, it can happen.
And then there's dudes are like,
I remember this guy man,
this guy just started doing Jujitsu.
He was as crazy Armenian dude.
I mean he had just started,
he was just learning techniques and he
would spar with anybody and this fucking
guy just would not tap.
He would fight to the death and
watching him roll with people. I'm like,
check this motherfucker out.
Like you would think he was
done and he would just die.
I just fucking struggling flat.
And he wasn't strong and he wasn't big.
He was just fucking proud.
It's shit and bound and
determined not to tap.
Not necessarily the best way to go
about it. And he had to get over that.
You gave us some respect. I'll fuck. Yeah.
Well I remember watching him because
it was one of his first classes and you
know, it's really, it's fascinating to me.
Fascinating to me watching people
just start Jujitsu. You know, the,
the Jujitsu digital guys were the
modern day jet I nights. Yeah. You know,
like Hixon would be like
the Yoda equivalent. Do you
know what I mean? It's like,
it's, it's kind of cool when
you think about it that way.
We have people who take ourselves to
the limit. Do you know what I mean?
And that's why there's such a
comradery between Digi two guys.
You know what I mean?
Like you know so much about it.
You do to guy when you shake his
hand. Yeah. Yeah. I think, um,
I think you have to ha,
I always talk about how well like Jujitsu
guys have control of their ego and
it's like, it was very rare you run into
Jujutsu guys completely out of control.
So many of our early guests were actually
Jujitsu guys cause it was who we knew
for London real.
And I'm like,
it must have had eight of them and the
guys and they were all just these cool,
grounded, pretty humble. Dude's still
smart, still excelling in their field,
but they were just, I don't know how they
get their checked on a regular basis.
That's what it is, man. It's
getting checked on a regular
basis. It's, it's huge.
It's so important. It's what I
said about the ego, your ego.
It leads you to victory.
It leads you to,
to want the glory and the accolades,
but ultimately a fucks you.
If you fight with your ego,
everybody knows
that you know you'll, you'll lose
your composure, you'll get crazy.
Especially if you start getting tagged,
you'll instead of fighting smart,
you'll just fucking flail back.
You'll try to attack back,
which is oftentimes the
total wrong approach.
Like you have to do the right thing
technically, so you have to, if you,
if you're going to do the right thing,
technically you have to be in
complete control. Your Ego,
you can't even let that factor into
the process. Look at it as a game.
You can sense that. I
mean his presence, he is,
we interviewed him on our show the other
day and one of the things I brought up
was I've known him for almost 10
years and Joe, I swear to God,
I've never seen him lose his cool.
He is the most zen person on the
planet or the one Muslim person I know.
And um,
it goes hand in hand with good Jujitsu.
Like I noticed the calmer
I'm getting as a human being,
maybe it's good to the aging of
meditation, the better my Jiu Jitsu is,
the more I'm in touch with reality when
I'm like sparring with someone. And uh,
I find that interesting.
I do as well.
I think Jujitsu is an excellent part
of daily life for a man especially.
And I think it's just one aspect.
The other is our nutrition philosophy,
thought conversation, conversation
with others. You know, I know this,
this podcast for sure.
You know,
people talk about how much
this podcast has helped them.
What's helped me too because it's helped
me really review a lot of the ideas
that I have in my head and my, my take
on things. And, and really, uh, in, in,
in projecting it out to other people
and or broadcasting it out to people.
You,
you also are forced to sort of take a
real account of all your thoughts and it's
sort of like teaching Jujitsu, which
your game better. He learned by teaching.
If you teach Jujitsu, man, you're going to
empathize, right? Yeah. My friend Brent,
perfect example was always like a
decent purple belt. Always a, you know,
but he,
he wasn't like the best guy and man,
he started fucking teaching,
he's a black belt now but he started
teaching and when he was teaching within a
year,
his game went up so many notches.
Like all of a sudden he
was dangerous as fung.
All of a sudden every time you rolled
with them he was snatching Camorra's
you're like,
oh,
this is like he's doing this perfect like
we had the tech is technique became so
sharp.
Do you know why that is?
I actually find out the other day because
I noticed that as well when I started
teaching full time. I've got, I've
got quite a lot better and we have,
I don't know if I'm
using the correct term,
but this specific kind of neuron in our
brain that fires when we see someone
doing something, it's, I think
it's called an empathy neuron.
And so when you're a teacher,
you watch your students in a,
I don't know about your process
when you teach them a bit. For me,
I watch what they do and I kind of,
in my mind I overlay
what it should look like.
There's like a mental video overlay and
then eventually I'll show them what to
do and they'll do it correctly.
And it's kind of like me doing
the technique again. Does
that make sense? Yes. So,
um,
I guess that's what's happening when you
watch someone else doing something or
if you just involved in the process,
that's where you can get
better watching fight video's.
Absolutely. Yeah. And having knowledge
of what to do already in your head,
like having especially patterns.
Like the other day I was in, I,
I had this guy in side control and he
tried to get up to one knee and as he
tried to get up to one knee, I took
us back and it was all in one second.
The whole thing was like, you know it all
just like, you know, it happens. Like you,
you, you couldn't think if even if
you were like an athletic person,
you wouldn't be able to do it
like that because you know what,
what's happening is your mind
is being bypassed. Your Buddy,
my parents first coach always said to me,
he used to say,
your body knows what to do
but your mind gets in the way.
And that's when that happens for
me is the most beautiful. So crazy.
Cause it happens and it's
really is like magic.
It's like all the sudden you
got this dude's back. Gosh,
you know, it's like, and,
and, and especially if you freak a
guy out, like he's like, Holy Shit,
I just got to get my back like that. Like
Marcello's my favorite example of that,
when you watch like
Marcels arm drag to back,
there's a moment where these guys can't
even believe this motherfucker got their
back so quick. Like how did he do that?
You know, my buddy, my friend Alexis, um,
he's a high level black ball now.
This is one of those guys a little bit,
a little bit skinny,
you know like so,
but he's reasonably his leg but he's
not like an Olympian, you know, so he's,
he's quite a fragile guys light. It's
like 150, hundred and 60 pounds and he,
he's so God damn technical
like he is literary like,
like a surgeon wielding the scalpel.
And he told me he went to train with
Marcello and he said, he said to me, nick,
I swear to God it felt like that man
was reading my mind. Every move I did.
He knew if I went to put my hand down to
get my balance, cause it off balance me,
he had grabbed my hand and then he had no,
I'd reached to counter with
the other hand and he'd read,
have already have something queued up.
She said it was like reading my mind.
He robbing him. Yeah. No, I've
never rolled with him. So I mean,
just think like for a high level
blackball to say that about my solo.
Isn't that exciting? We can all one day
get perhaps close to that level. Yeah.
The best guys I wrote
with John Jacques Machado,
a role with him pretty regularly.
I've rolled with Eddie Bravo a bunch
of times of course. And uh, he's,
which, and Denny Denny proper goals
was one of Eddie's black belts.
He's got a nasty guard
and he's on small dude.
He's only about 160 pounds and he's still,
yeah.
And he's still contact me from the
guard regularly. He's wicked. Yeah,
there's a lot.
He's got a,
Eddie's got a lot of guys that just have
stupid guards should get keys and other
ones. This dude. And he's, you
know, 135 pounds. What do you enjoy?
You like her card or a
pastor or what's your style?
I've changed much more over the years
and tried to be much more guard oriented
and half guard oriented and earn,
earn top position. You know,
because I,
most of my game,
most of my submissions were from the
top and I realize that's unrealistic.
Maricio um, I mean, he's a seventh,
he's a red and a red and white,
red and black belt. So I mean this guy
is legit. And he said to me, I said,
when I was up quite a bit younger,
I said like, man, you know,
Merito I thought about it like I don't
want to play on my back because if I'm on
my backup,
just trying to get to the top anyway,
so why don't I just go straight to
top? And he said, you know, Nick,
when you get older you'll see you'll need
your God, you'll need it. Cause it's,
there's much more energy conservation
when you're on your back. And, um,
I didn't think about it, but all I
get, you know, I kind of see that,
I know what he was talking about. I like
to earn it, you know, that's what Eddie,
he says if you're going to
attack someone from the top,
you should earn that position. So I
always start off from guard a 10th planet.
Well I've been injured, I've been injured
for five months. I fucked my backup.
And what I tried to do was I tried to
just like a lightly role and he's like an
asshole. Even though I knew
it was injured, I was like,
I just like roll with like guys, no, go
hard. And then I fucked it up way worse.
And the one day where I tried to look
rolled light set me back three months.
Then I came back and I only trained for
a couple of days and I popped it out
again. But it was much more
mild this time. It was,
it just a bad muscle tear and a,
it's in my back.
It's where a year like in
between your shoulder blades,
like that's where I tore the muscle is
just really weird. It was a Jujitsu thing.
Are you gonna be rolling to,
you're like 65 do you think?
Or later you'd be like Helio
Gracie till the wheels fall off
rolling until the wheels fall off.
I mean,
I've got to say it was nice during the
five months that I was off where I didn't,
I was, it wasn't always tweaked.
It was always like my elbow,
like I should have tapped from that
and I muscled out of it or my neck got
tweaked or it's always something I
don't know about you. But um, for me,
and I'm sure from a few other
GC guys, you know, when you,
when you get to the end of a hard week
of training and you're just fucked,
everything hurts. And you've got
that like bone tiredness. Yeah, yeah.
I used to like fight against it,
but now I kind of get off on that.
Do you know what I mean?
I feel like in my body I'm alive.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Well, you also feel like you've,
you've earned relaxation. You've actually
done something incredibly difficult.
Like I had a great role last
night and, uh, I came home,
this is my third time back
from the injury and I'm like,
I'm finally like pretty sure that
it's, it's, if it's not 100%,
it's definitely 90%.
So I'm feeling great and it was just
fucking exhausted and I just plopped down
on the couch and watch TV, but I didn't
feel guilty at all about watching TV.
You know,
it's like I did something pretty fucking,
I put forth some serious effort and I
don't feel like I can enjoy like bullshit,
like fucking off, like watching
TV or something, unless
I've done something hard.
I feel like you should reward
yourself with bullshit like,
but it's all a matter of managing
it. You know? It's like, I like to,
I like to watch TV or watch a movie after
I've written for a few hours, you know,
or I just like, okay, I did
my work. I can just shut off
now, man, I can't do it. Joe,
you know, just telling Brian the other day
I sold my playstation in my TV. I just,
I realized I don't want it in my
house anymore man because you know,
it sounds a bit strange but I always
feel kind of empty after watching TV or,
and it's not porn, um,
or playing video games.
I don't feel like I've grown as a person.
I feel like it was just like,
like a vegetable,
you know?
And I'm happy to have it at the house
while there's a very different feeling
that get from playing video
games than I get from doing other
things that are difficult. Like pool,
I played pool, which is also a lot of
people would say is a waste of time.
You know? Like they always say
that if someone is good at pool,
it's a glorious results of a misspent
youth. You know, that's what you did.
That's what people describe
like a really good pool player.
But I feel that pool in a lot of ways
is a lot like Jujitsu cause it's a lot,
a lot about managing your nerves.
It's a lot about control of your body.
It's a lot about concentration.
It's not as fast paced, but it's,
it's pretty intense when
you play high level pool.
And so to me it's not just a game,
it's also,
there's a lot of exercise going on there.
There's a lot of exercise of control
and composure and then you know,
in striking the ball in judging
how hard to hit it, you'll,
you'll literally are judging
how much energy you release,
your like controlling the effort.
And it's very important because you
can't hit everything full blast.
It's not like, you know, boxing, we,
he tried to knock somebody
out in the first round.
You could just get away
with all power punches.
You have to have a real good sense of
how likely or how hard you need to hit
that ball and you need to be able to
control that ball with the levels level
sticks. So you need to figure out
how to drive through it level.
As you're coming down. There's a lot
of thinking and weirdness going on.
If you look at it like if I'm from a big,
big picture perspective,
there's some philosophy Alan
Watts. And he says, yeah,
I think he was around in the 60s,
the 70s. And he was saying how, um,
you'll get these wealthy
people who they'll buy a huge
boat and then they wonder
why it doesn't make them happy.
And it's because pleasure
comes from the acquisition,
the process of acquiring a skill. It
doesn't come from like a material object.
And um, that made a lot
of sense to me. You know,
that's why like when you go
and you'd get on the mat,
like now I find digits is the most fun
now that I'm a black belt because I've
acquired that skill and I
can just enjoy it. I'm not,
I'm not trying too hard to get better.
I'm just enjoying my skill and getting
pleasure from it. You know what I mean?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Yeah. Like, you know, when
you, when you have a good role,
like say you get in there with a good
purple belt or something like that,
someone was real scrappy and you'd go
and you're countering each other and you
attack and counter each other
and then you finally know,
catch a dude with something and it's
like, man, you earn that shit. You know,
it's a,
this,
there's something beautiful about
pulling off a technique on an unwilling
participant. You know, when you've,
you've figured out a way to bypass
his defenses and you get in and,
and it's a fascinating game of intellect
and that's what people don't understand.
It's not just a physical thing.
There's certainly physical aspects to it.
Especially I feel them now because I'm
just getting back into Jujitsu shape.
Cause even if you work out,
it's not the same.
The only thing that comes
closest kettlebells,
there's especially a kettlebell workout
called extreme kettlebell cardio workout.
It's company called dragon door sells it.
And this,
this motherfucker puts you through hell.
I mean,
it's a light light kettlebell too.
He does it with a 35 pound kettle bell.
And I would've never believed that someone
could give me a good workout with a
little pussy ass 35 pound weigh in
my bitch. Like where's the 70s son?
Let me show you what the fuck is
up. But if I'm sure, how long was
it? God, it's 20 minutes. 45 minutes
man. And by the end of 45 minutes,
45 minutes with like a minute break here
and there in between sets it's Ruth,
the less it's ruthless,
your fucking legs want to die.
It's like they're going to break.
You feel like you're going to step and
your muscle is just going to fall off
your leg. Like you've,
you've ripped it all apart.
If you get through that 45 minutes
without Kettlebell, congratulations.
You're a beast. Yeah. Brian's a big show
coming up. Well before I ask a trip,
like Brian's like I gotta do my Kettlebell
workout in the morning because it
puts you in a good mood and
tried to get in the right zone.
It puts those endorphins going, man.
It, it fires up your system, you know,
gets your testosterone production up
that when you're doing like re like they
always say that the best exercises for
putting on mass or a full body exercises
like dead lifts traditionally squats,
things along those lines where your
whole body has to move as a unit far more
effective for putting on like real size
and functional strength and like say
just bench press or just curls or
something along those, you know,
if you look at someone who is primary
supplemental training outside,
did you too is um, bodybuilding. You
can see they just don't move, right?
It's not the way the human body
was designed to move through space.
You know that like they're
all luck through the chest
and shoulders and there's
no like horizontal movement in their hips.
There's only linear movement.
Cause if you think about you're
pushing like 400 pounds on a leg press,
it's a very,
your muscles and your tendons,
your ligaments and your bones get used
to working in a very specific direction.
There's no like balance and a,
and flexibility in it.
So I got a question about Aubrey when
he's on here and talking about all his
crazy,
like he boga I remember you and Brian
were listening to him talking about Yoga
and you're like,
I don't ever want to do stuff like that.
And when he talks about Iowasca is that
stuff that you guys just are like, never,
I never want to touch that stuff.
Oh, do, I'll ask in a heartbeat.
I'm not worried about
Iowasca I'm again seems, uh,
I think it would be great for someone
who had real serious personality issues,
substance addiction, substance
abuse issues. I don't have those.
So I am, Hancock was talking
about the boat and he's like,
I don't want to do it again.
The closest I have to a substance
abuse issue is coffee. I love coffee.
It's a powerful, you're
IOWASCA coffee. Oh.
Oh. Will ask it at somebody's died the
other day from the supposedly, yeah,
but they don't know if the
IOWASCA killed him. Pete. Yeah.
Some of the showman
could have killed them.
The sham cause the showman buried him.
So who knows if he died
during a ceremony or you know,
he might've been an asshole,
somebody about to kill them.
You really legit. Sharman
like, like an old school. Yeah.
He was in some movie before that and
like, yeah. And like a legit movie.
And then apparently this kid's dead.
So it's writing that drag off. Now.
One guy dies me while
he smoked cigarettes.
Hilarious cigarettes kill 500,000
people a year in this country alone.
And he's like, well, it's fucking
Iowasca killed one asshole in Peru.
Iowasca the drug that he said, it makes
you feel like you're dying in the home.
Have. Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Fuck
that drug. I think we both said fuck
that drug. I think, I think it's very
beneficial for certain people. I,
I have a friend, my friend Ed who
runs a center down in Mexico, um, uh,
ed class, one of the Lloyd Irvin's black
belts, um, great guy. And he's, um,
he's, his whole life
changed because of Ibogaine.
He took it and went down and he
had an issue with pain pills.
He had got an injury.
And like a lot of guys that get injured
and the doctor prescribing something,
especially if you fuck up your back.
It happened to someone I know very,
very well. It was a construction
worker hurt his back.
Strong opiate, isn't it? It's terrifying.
It's very terrifying that it's so readily
available that doctors will prescribe
it so easily and that they're trusting
you to have control that giving you all
these pills all at once.
It's not like you go to the doctor and
every day he dispenses you a new one and
it says, listen, I'll give you,
you want to get on Oxycontin,
I will give it to you,
but you got to come to
me. I give you one. No,
he used a whole bottle of 90 fucking
pills. If you want to take four at a time,
you can take four at a time.
No one's going to stop you.
So it's weird that we're in London.
We don't have that readily
accessible opiate prescriptions.
We have an incredibly hypocritical
society, especially in Florida, Florida.
They would have done documentaries on it.
Um,
that show 'em the vanguard had
the, uh, the oxycontin express.
It was a show dedicated just to
oxycontin where they showed that Florida,
they have these ridiculous laws where you,
I think they're trying to change that
now probably because of vanguard probably
because of that oxycontin express show,
but they have these things
called pain management centers.
So say you come in and you
say, Hey, uh, you know,
I hurt my back and uh, really it's fucking
painful. I can't even sleep. And like,
okay, well I'm going write you
a prescription for pain pills.
And then you take it and you shut
that door and you open the next door,
the same building.
They're connected and that's the pharmacy
and they have your pain pills and it's
all they have is that continue to
exist because there's corruption.
And by the way,
Florida is also the state that has
recently come under fire for hiring police
officers to pretend to be high school
students, to get kids to sell him pot.
They hired a 25 year
old woman who was hot.
She was attractive to make friends with
a 17 year old boy who was an honor roll
student. This kid tested
negative, by the way,
does it didn't have any pot in his
system, didn't do drugs, didn't have a,
didn't have a record smug kit.
Just a kid. Yeah, just a kid.
And she made friends with them and then
got him to sell her weed and then they
had, they had him arrested and she
coerced him. I mean she's 25 years old.
She's a woman. Okay. And she's dealing
with a boy and she's attractive.
First of all,
that's completely unfair.
The attractive woman have a massive amount
of power. [inaudible] oh boy. Ashley,
over 17 years, especially in attractive,
attractive 25 year old woman.
I mean that's a real woman and he smells
that when a boy would smell that and
the affection for that woman
would be like super special.
So you know what's funny is sickness.
But when I was younger, like my fantasy
was an older woman. Then the older
you get it kind of switches around
that are all,
as you get older and younger fantasies.
Younger woman threw him for
a loop and he was like, oh,
I just didn't know if you
were done. I thought you were
going to keep going. Yeah,
yeah, I know what you mean.
Yeah. It's, that's a weird thing.
But some dudes know there's like
the whole MILF market and porn.
So goods are into like this really
dirty look and 40 year olds just fucking
savage,
just cock monsters as four year old
fucking with Mascara of sweat nude,
all that. A lot of those
videos dudes are into that now.
It's women who just want to get
gorilla fucked. Older women are just,
they know what they want.
That's like a whole market dirty milk.
What's pretty you pretty freaky mocket
as well. What's this movie called?
Samsara recently.
The SQL to Berakah and um,
you know it says a bunch of long shots
with no dialogue and they showed this.
It was the most bizarre
thing I've ever seen.
The sex doll factory and
then they juxtapose that
shot with one of those strip
clubs slash brothels in Thailand
and to make a point. And it,
it showed you just how similar the
whole thing is the sex industry. I mean,
do you know what I mean?
Selling sex dolls and selling human
beings is pretty much the same,
the same thing. And in that case, that's,
that's fascinating to are you guys,
you guys move into Wester? No,
it was talking about here too.
And you always talk about like what you
want to do with that squad and with the
podcast and I'm like, well, you know,
I think you said recently you would like
feel a responsibility to kind of like
take this to another level and stuff.
I'm just wondering what you meant by that.
Well, um, the, the only thing
we're doing differently is one,
I have a new studio that I'm opening
up. It's closer to where I live. Um,
and it's a completely independent thing.
It's not connected to a comedy
club and it's got a lot of space.
So the idea is that we can have it set
up the way I would like to have it set up
where, you know, have a nice
cameras and monitors on the wall.
But you're not getting rid
of red band, right? No.
I've had this motherfucker with me
for 10 years. I'm not going anywhere.
He's Brian's one of my best
friends. I mean, he's not just a,
and he's a weird
motherfucker, but you don't,
you don't get some weird dude. He's
into Hitler cats. That's just, that's,
it's hard to find.
Hard to find.
So he's an important element.
So he's going to be placed where like
people hang out or is it going to get
studio? Oh, Brian's going to be with
me this weekend, by the way. Um,
we're going to be in Phoenix at stand
up alive and it's going to be fucking
crazy. Folks. Uh, Joey Diaz is there
a, he won't be there on Sunday,
but he's there Friday and Saturday.
Um,
and Ari Shaffir is going
to be there on Friday.
Brendan Walsh going to be in on Saturday.
Brian's going to be there the whole week.
We're going to have a fucking blast.
But we haven't been a Phoenix.
Uh, it's been a couple of years.
One of my favorite places like
that in Texas. It's a cool town.
Did you hear they bought the other bus?
Yeah, they bought the Tempe Improv too.
Good for them. You still get
nervous? I get excited, right? Yeah.
Not Nervous. I'm looking forward to
doing it. I just, it's a, it's important.
So I get excited.
I wouldn't say nervous with that
implies like fear. It's not a fear thing.
It's like, it's an excitement. Like,
uh, you have to be heightened.
You definitely, you can't
like go up nonchalant.
Me People want to be entertained.
They want to be it.
They want it to feel the
intensity of the performance.
They want to feel the focus.
They want to be entertained,
so you have to be up for it. So it's
an exciting thing. It's not a nerve.
But if I didn't do my job though,
I would feel fucking nervous.
Like if I haven't been writing,
I don't know what to say.
And, uh, you know, there's,
there's,
there's a weird fear that
comes with trying new shit
and fucking around with new
bits, especially if not convinced.
Like sometimes I'll have a bit and uh,
I'll start out with it and I'm like,
man, this bit is this my fucking suck,
this pit my suck. This might have been
just one of those stone ramblings.
And then I'll do it on stage and I'll
find a path and all of a sudden it becomes
a monster. It's like onstage, it'll become
alive and the have to take that chance.
Sometimes there's two aspects to writing.
One aspect is the physical act of
sitting in front of a keyboard,
writing in silence by myself.
There's that for sure.
That's a very important aspect of it.
But the other aspect of it is
telling the story in front of people,
telling the bit in front of people
because then the motherfucker just comes
alive then. Then I know like I
was going to say it a certain way,
but in the moment I got another one.
I don't need that part.
I need to edit that part out and just
get right to this part. Boom, boom.
And it's a matter of editing on stage.
It's one of the few art forms that
you must have an audience to create.
You have to, I cannot create, I can,
sorry, I can start the process on my own,
but I can't create the audience without
any audience. We'll do any, oh well,
I mean hopefully a good one. But, um,
I can't create the standup. I can't,
it can't become its full form
without the crown. It's impossible.
I used their energy. That's part
of the equation, right? Yeah.
It's a part of the reaction is part of it.
The feel I get from him,
the intangibles, like
as I'm saying it, the,
where I know the timing lies and it's,
it's so,
it would be impossible to describe such
a specialized skill. It's a weird skill.
It's a, it's, it's, it's see, cause it's
not, it's not what everybody thinks it is,
man. It's not just your, you know,
you're saying things and people are
considering what you're saying and they're
laughing. Ha Ha. There's
a little bit of that.
But there's also some
weird fucking connection,
some hypnosis thing that's going
on between the audience. Yeah,
and as an audience member,
I feel it as well.
Like when I watch someone who I
think is really hilarious, like a,
when I saw Stan hope recently or
when I saw a Joey Diaz the other day,
like when someone is really killing
and you're locked into their bit, it's,
there's a,
there's,
there's this weird sort of a
connection and the you as a performer,
you feel that and then when you're coming
up with new shit, it's like you've,
you'll feel where it goes and where,
and they also feel when you're faking
it and you feel when it's forced,
you feel like all these deals
and you know what they feel,
you know what the audience feels.
It's like you're conducting this here.
It's really a pure art form.
It's a fucking weird art form.
It's typically a hard comedy course.
And I did five minutes in
London and so it was chippy.
I mean I know a lot of people
hate on comedy courses.
I know Marin hates on comedy
courses, but he shouldn't, you know,
because it gets people in the door and
it gets them out of their shell. Right?
Yeah. If you don't know anything about
standup, if you're not a standup comedian,
you know what you, why not take a course
to get you to force yourself on stage?
You know the real problem with courses
is a lot of them are run by the losers.
That's the problem,
but you need a funny guy to teach you
or do you need the guy really to get you
on stage and then so
you can learn yourself.
You're not going to get real comedy
advice from somebody who sucks. Yeah.
I don't think it's okay.
They can't do it. Yeah.
There was a bunch of people that wrote
books on comedy and they were like,
you know,
I remember as a young professional when
I had just started getting paid to do
gigs, people would just laugh
at these books, but a horrible,
the comic who actually wrote the book was,
but what a book does do.
Even though I agree with that in certain
ways it does get you interested in the
conversation.
It does.
Like you might like go to the bookstore
and say how to be a standup comic man,
I need a fucking find a
book on how to be a comic.
And then that book might be step one
taking class might be stepped to 10 years
from now. You might be Mark Marin, you
know, you might be a Mark Marin, you know,
you might be a real professional comedian.
It's just a matter of taking those steps.
And so the good thing that a comedy class
does is that allows you to fuck around
and get on stage and see if
this is something that you're
actually interested in.
And, and, and just think about
the process of it. And by the way,
when you're in a bad comedy class,
listening to idiots tell you how to do,
you might be like, this guy's an
idiot and that might help your comedy.
Like that might help you understand that
there's a lot of people out there that
do it terrible. Don't do what this
guy's doing. Don't hack it up up there.
Don't make it so obvious. Don't insult
me as a person is watching, you know,
like you might feel insulted and
that actually might benefit you in an
educational sort of a way.
Just kind of been sucked every week in
front of these people and we all bonded
at the end cause like he's
12 strangers and it's like,
if you can't make 12 random people in
London laughed and most likely you're not
going to make a comedy audience laugh. And
we just got up there. I would just say,
oh by the way, tomorrow night we have a
show here. We have a show here at the, uh,
at the ice house. Um, Joey Diaz and
I were on the phone today. It's like,
what are we doing tomorrow, dog?
And I go, what do you want to do?
Is we've got to do a fucking show.
We've got to do a fucking show.
We can't come in cold
the Phoenix cause like,
we're not coming in cold to Phoenix dog.
We got to give these motherfuckers
are Valerie's house a show. So I said,
all right. All right, we're
going to do a show, sell down.
Is it like breathing for you guys? You
guys got to be on stage, um, weekly. Well,
Joey is, um, you know, Joey's
a guy who, no matter what,
Joey's always doing three, four sets a
week. He's always hopping around doing it.
He loves it.
It's one of the reasons why he's so good,
so comfortable and natural up there.
And it's just also what he loves.
He's a real stand up, you know, he's
a, he's a black belt in standup comedy.
He loves it. He loves it. It's the
same thing. So for him it's like,
he knows that we're going to have
these huge crowds. It's Phoenix,
the club is like 600 seats. So it's,
it's, and it's almost sold out.
So it's going to be nuts.
Two shows Friday, two shows
Saturday and one show on.
So Joey's just fucking ramping up
right now. He's fucking shadowbox.
And in his house we
invited him on London Real,
but then he told us he doesn't
have a passport, so can't
go to London. Yeah, yeah.
That sucks. That's too bad because a,
that would be awesome to have him on.
It would, yeah. You guys could
experience the love you. Um,
can you tell is someone who's like,
um,
you're like a belt and some comedy as
well. So can you tell when you meet your,
when you meet a new colleague appeared,
can you tell if they're a natural or if
there's someone who had average talent
and really polished it to a high degree,
you could tell if they're a
douchebag and if there a douchebag,
they're probably not
going to be that good.
There's something I'm telling
you it's going to be fake.
They're going to be clunky.
And then there's some people you meet and
they're just so open. There's so like,
and you're like, Whoa, I gotta
see what this guy does on stage.
You know what I mean? Like some
people you meet them and they're,
they're just really there and centered
and engage in you and you're like, oh,
this is a sharp motherfucker. Like what's
going on when he's talking to you? Yeah.
You know?
And then there's other guys that are
like really quiet and then they get on
stage and there a mother fucker.
You know, you never know. It's,
it's people's personalities or strange.
There's some people that are completely
different on stage and they are offstage.
It's weird.
You know,
in some people they're really
fucking funny on stage and
then offstage they just,
you know, kinda quiet, reserved,
you know it's very strange.
It's like they get it all out in their
onstage antics. This, there's that too.
There's a lot of
different types of comedy.
The most taxing and exhausting is the
always on fucking one liner guy who's
always trying to like say
like the next funny thing.
But you guys do crack jokes when
you guys are hanging out. Yeah,
but only the ones that work.
Okay.
You've got to know what's your,
it's the same thing we were
talking about being a black belt.
It's like you got to know what is actually
funny and you've got to know what is
just annoying to listen to.
You know,
what is just you jerking off into the
wind and what is actually something that's
relative, like something that relevant,
something, something relevant to bring up.
Something that you're actually
contributing to the conversation. You,
you took the term like one of the
things that Brian's really good at,
and I wanna encourage this,
but I have to give him his props.
He'll say some shit that I would have
never fucking thought up and I would have
never said. And he'll interject them
in weird spots and it just like,
it takes the conversation. Sometimes
it works, sometimes it doesn't,
but it takes it to a place
that you probably would
have never gone on your own.
And that's what's fun in
having a conversation.
What's fun and having a conversation.
And what's fun in,
in watching a standup comedian is someone
who can take shit to places where you
know, you might not have gone, but
the relevant, they're relevant places.
So it's like you allow them to think
for you for a brief moment. You know,
you allow that. And when someone, when
they're, they're awkward and Clunky,
you know, like you can't think for me
stupid like, what are you doing here?
You're bullshitting me.
It's like,
so when you say that someone's exhausting,
cause they're always joke yucking it up.
Like they don't understand
how they're being perceived
there.
There's a disconnect between what they're
projecting and what they're imagining
their projecting or how they're
being received and what,
how they're imagining
their being received.
There's a disconnect
there and that that's a,
that's just like the karate guy who
still thinks he's a master and he's got a
gut now, but he wants everybody
to be terrified of him
and he really does believe
somewhere in the back of his head
that he could fucking handle multiple
attackers. You know,
he's, he's bullshitting.
That's the scariest thing in life
is when you're confronted with,
when your delusions are shown to,
you know what I mean? Thank you.
The Mac and then he'd just get the story
and that's why I told you not to eat
that cookie.
This motherfucker was trying to give you
have no cookies and you don't want to
fuck with these edibles, man, edibles,
edibles will put you in a bad place.
Miss you're ready foot.
It's very confronting.
You know? It's like,
it just confronts you with all the weird
shit that you've been pushed into the
back of your head and it's
like, I was Scott then. Well,
have you ever seen the information
on the difference between consuming
marijuana?
Can you talk about anyone?
Other cannabinoids change on the first
pass through the liver, right? Yeah.
And the first pass through the
liver becomes 11 hydroxy metabolite,
which is this intense psychedelic drug,
which is five times more psychoactive
than THC. So for a portion of marijuana,
like say what's in a pot brown,
it just,
if you smoked it would
fucking get you high shit.
But if you eat it like
it's almost uncomfortable.
It's like so self examine
a Tory and so intensely,
you know, probing to all aspects of
your fears and an unconscious thoughts.
That's why you do it on a plane.
You know what I was saying?
I was in that I about five
years ago and someone gave me a,
Ronnie had never had one before
and he picked me up in the morning.
So this is for you.
We want to wear to universal studios,
which had never been to before. So I ate
this thing on an empty stomach and um,
I got really paranoid and I chicken out
on the Shrek ride, man. Like I literally,
I lost it. I said, I gotta get Outta here.
There were all these mirrors
on the walls wailing and quote
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt. I'm scared
of Shrek rise. That's a new meme now.
That's a meme on the Rogan
board. Brazilian Jujitsu.
Black belt. Scared of Shrek,
right?
Yeah.
Man
needs a motherfucker sign nothing.
Nothing.
There's a lot of people say
it makes you paranoid. And I,
I believe that a certain amount
of paranoia is very important.
I really think it's not paranoia. I
think it's just sent me, how dare you.
That ringtone? Yeah. Yeah. I
don't change ringtones, bitch.
I don't want to hear your music either.
If you one of those dudes,
it's got some fucking latest.
Does Green Day have a latest song.
They might have a bad ass ring
too. They enjoy you sexy bitch. Um,
both sex hand the fuck were we talking?
I don't know,
but I've got to drop some
financial science on you. I
had an appointment though.
You've planned your ring
tone. Oh, that's Kinda cool.
If you get forgot that it certainly
wasn't worth talking about.
I was talking too much shit obviously.
All right, so my job from long
science here. Yeah, it sure.
Can we have it of science? Yeah.
I kind of look Trump a little bit.
So I know you're always talking about
the crazy derivatives and how there's too
many amount there and it's
betting on like fake stuff. Well,
what I talk about is that I really,
I'm a fucking idiot.
I don't really understand it.
So if I'm saying it,
I'm just repeating some shit I
heard online. Fair enough. So,
so I'll just like real break it down. Like
the oldest form of derivative is like,
it's,
it's like what the Egyptians you steal
when they used to like grow some cotton
and like they'd got,
they'd know that they'd like sell it
for a future price and if they got a
certain price they would plant the crops.
And if they didn't then they wouldn't.
So that was like the oldest form and
then it kinda got crazy with this credit
derivatives and stuff.
And it's more just like technology is
the way I look at it. Like an Ipad,
you could say as bad if you like load
porn on it and give it to an eight year
old. But in theory it's not bad stuff. Uh,
the problem is is when it gets a
little unregulated and crazy. Well, a,
I see your point and I think that what
you're saying is probably correct,
but I think that if you want to
have a fair society and the society,
that makes sense.
I don't think you can have things
when it comes to money and finances.
that can be manipulated in any way,
shape or form or things that are based
at all on confidence or perceptions of
how something is doing.
So when I look at the stock
apples down in over the iPhone,
it was a lump and perceived as a little
fork on and we thought it was apple
stock goes down. What are you even
saying? What the fuck are you even saying?
What kind of crazy world we live in,
where there's people,
the regular people who are gambling for
and against a company falling apart,
are doing well.
And that's a part of our
society and that's a part of
our economy. That's crazy.
Every time you buy something
and you're kind of gambling,
when you buy your house and wherever you
live, you actually were thinking it'll,
it'll probably be a good investment
as opposed to if you bought a house in
Tiawana than it may be wouldn't.
So every decision you make with
your money is kind of a bit sure.
If I was saying that you should
never gamble, that would make sense.
But that's not what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is you can't gamble on
shit that you're not even a part of and
that can't be a giant part of the economy.
You like when you,
when you're buying stock and selling
stock and trading stock and things are
going up and down,
the Dow is down seven points today.
What the fuck are you even talking about?
You've got a shit system.
If the Dow is down that if it's that
fluctuating up and down based on some
stupid fucking build it gets
passed or some lack of cower.
Iran has been rattling their sabers,
the Dow is down, you know, it's,
that's a nonsense system. Humans are
all about confidence, right? If it,
if someone's, if, sure. But our economy
shouldn't be based on such a weird,
you know, a theorial sort of a
feeling like the idea that you know,
whether or not people believe that apples
on the ride. What about blackberry?
Why the fuck are block bar now?
They were on top of the
world at one point in time.
So it just seems like nonsense.
It seems like piece of gold
should equal one donkey. Okay.
Back to the old school until we
figure out how to have a, I mean,
what was the guy's name? The young joc
fresco talks about resource based economy.
That's the only thing that makes sense.
Economies based on numbers and derivatives
and finances and stocks and bonds and
why do you even saying,
I just don't know how we're going to
get there without having a complete
bloodbath.
How are we going to get to a better
version of government without a complete,
you only say the Internet and that's the
only option we have right now. Right.
I think that's,
I think the Internet is eventually
going to be the governing of the world,
the governing of the world.
It's going to lead to the governing
of the world through the people.
I think it's only inevitable as long as
people continue to have more and more
access to information and more and more
power to distribute that information
like we do right now.
And that's one of the scariest things
about these tightening up bills when the
bill,
you know,
when they're trying to stop the passing
these cyber terrorism bills and these
sweeping legislation that allows the
government to come in and shut down
websites and, and deem, you know,
enemies of the state, certain wet,
like wikileaks is an enemy of
the state. Now, Julian Assan,
Julian Assange is deemed an enemy of
the state. They've decided he's as bad.
It's al Qaeda. He's meanwhile,
all he's done is tell the truth.
Always done is distributed information
that the government didn't want
distributed. So they decided that
this guy's a fucking terrorist.
Are you going to carry, I think it's
nonsense. I mean, as I get older,
I think it's more and more nonsense
and I think it's a silly system.
If Gary Johnson can't debate, okay,
what you got is you gotta rig system.
You've got a giant crazy rig fake system.
And if I pretend that I'm a part of
this stupid electorial college and,
and hop on board, it's nonsense.
College is still crazy, right?
Every aspect of it is nuts.
Lobbyists are nuts.
The ability to donate
corporation's ability to donate
limitless amounts of money.
That's nuts. That's just this term,
this latest super pacs and all that.
That's nuts.
It's weird watching it from London.
It's really weird because it seems like
a big joke with Romney and Obama and it
shows like a big guy. Myself Draconian
Mitt Romney on Facebook last night. Joe,
good for her. It was like a
nice guy. I liked him too.
It doesn't mean that would vote for
him and even if you vote for him,
I think it's been pretty obvious with
Obama that it's not that easy. Um,
and what Obama's done.
Everybody thought that Obama was going
to be this great savior, this country,
and it's going to, you know,
I mean, I remember her,
this woman who was a like all happy
when he won it and now I know that my
mortgage is going to be paid and now I
know that I was listening to her say it
was like,
Whoa,
you want to talk about some
high expectations for someone
who's going to come in
and you think he's going to
fix this incredibly fucking
entangled corrupt system,
not of his hands, Matt fix it, but
he let some shit get past that.
I would have never thought that the
National Defense Authorization Act,
which allows the military to
break up civil descent they met,
allows the military to
be used on US civilians.
It allows people to be
held without authorization.
It allows to be w without
rather representation, without
any recourse. You can't,
you can't have a trial.
They can just hold you indefinitely
as long as everyone is terrifying.
It's terrifying. They would
ask for that. Here's why.
It's not like things have gone
horribly bad in this country.
It's not like there's riots in the
streets every day and people are
assassinating government leaders and
there's bomb blowing up and buildings
everywhere and we have resorted to like
some sort of arcane law that we're going
to have to put into place
until we can calm things down.
We've got to control the,
no, it's not that, but cool.
Walk down the street Pasadena.
It's beautiful out here,
man. Get on the highway.
There's a few. Too many cars.
People are civil. You know,
you've got hours and hours of bumper to
bumper traffic and the worst thing is
somebody might blow the horn and
stick a finger out at somebody.
No one's cutting people's heads
off with swords. You know, it's,
it's not necessary to pass
these crazy Orwellian laws.
But what it makes me think is that they
can see the writing on the wall and they
know that this form of
running governments,
it's no longer valid. It doesn't
work. It's ridiculous. We,
we understand your influence,
we understand why you're
making these decisions.
We see where the money comes from now.
It's all readily available.
It's not like we're living in 1930 and
I have to read the Hearst newspapers to
find out what the information is,
you know,
is going to be about
this upcoming election.
You can find out anything
about anybody. It's, it's,
it's really different now and it's not
saying that we don't need a government.
We certainly need to government. It's not
saying we shouldn't have corporations.
Of course we should have corporations.
I,
there's a lot of corporations that I
think are great. I think Apple's great.
I think Porsche is great.
I think I like their products.
I think you know what I mean? I,
there's nothing wrong with that.
It's just we can't allow money to
supersede humanity and that's what they've
done.
They've allowed the idea of doing their
stockholders justice and making as much
money as possible.
They've allowed that to supersede humanity
and when you have businesses where
their entire function is to supersede
humanity, you can see that and you can,
you can measure that, that we need to
stop that. That needs to be closed down.
They got to stop it for themselves because
they're all having fucking horrible
Karma from that, you know?
And yeah, that's gotta be
best comparable man. If you,
have you thought about having
politicians on the show? A few.
We've got a guy that young David Seaman,
he's coming back again when the couple
of weeks want to come on your show or we
go, why don't we get one, two, maybe
Gary Johnson would, but he's, you know,
he's legit. You know, I spoke to Ron.
Paul had a chance to speak
to him on the tonight show.
I never asked him to come on the
podcast because I thought it would be
ridiculous. Siemens comes in. He wouldn't
come on. Yeah, he's coming on again.
But you have problem with that.
No, I said Siemens. How dare you
fucking child. There you go.
That's what you're talking.
Exactly like the needle off the records
of my manchild barking in the distance
to put your credit Joe.
So this is our one year anniversary pretty
much since for you guys to show. Yeah.
And I mean obviously it was, it was
pretty much after watching your show.
I mean the splitscreen
was pretty much an owed.
He used to shoot it I think
at your house, right? Yeah.
Well we started doing it because
of, uh, Anthony coolio. Really.
He was the big push. I mean,
when, uh, we went to, um, uh,
the Anthony show and Anthony has a show
called live from the compound and he was
the,
he actually has a fucking six set up.
He has a green screen and a broadcast
desk and really high end microphones.
And Him and his buddies would get
drunk and do a show. And we were like,
me and Brian were like, Dad looks fun.
Is it video as well? Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
So we started doing it all.
It'll be three years for us in December.
We started doing it on just on a
Ustream, on a, on a, on a laptop.
And you guys were on sofas,
right? And then, yeah,
we didn't in my house
just chilling at my house.
We were bored when you're infected us
over in London, you know. Well, you know,
like I said,
we were infected first.
We've come up with this idea
called global real. And we want to,
we want to facilitate the setting up of
like some of the things in real in every
major city in the world or anybody
who wants to just do a podcast.
We've talked to some guys actually
in Victoria, British Columbia.
There's a guy over there,
Eric Faust,
and we talked to him recently on Skype
and he's like, I want to do a podcast.
I'm like, just do it. You
know, if you want some help,
let's do it. And he's like,
I want to call it Victoria real with
your permission. And I was like, dude,
that's awesome. I know the
name, you know, but I was like,
this is not another London
real. You're good. Right.
We'll have to bust. This is up.
There can't be enough podcasts right
now. I don't that I, I, you know,
there's a lot of people that feel like
the other people that are doing podcasts
or somehow or another, the competition.
I don't feel that at all. I never have.
I feel like there's 300 million fucking
human beings just in this country and
hundreds of millions worldwide that
also listen to anything English.
I think this is a huge
audience for everybody and I,
I don't think that it has
to be us against them. I,
I'm inspired by other comedians just
like I'm inspired by other podcasts,
but I'm a big,
I'm a big believer in the way to be
successful in the way to feel good is to
help other people, to help other people
do things mentality though. Yeah.
That's one of the first signs of an
enlightened human being as he knows is
enough for everyone. He doesn't have to
claw and scrape and say, this is mine.
You know?
And once you start sending that energy
out into the universe to experience
becomes very, very different.
Right. I think my standup comedy,
all of it has benefited from that. My
life has benefited from it. I'm just to,
I think you have to be a generous person.
I'm like,
I'll regularly go to a coffee shop and
leave like a hundred dollar tip. I just,
I think you've got to do that. I think
I leave like a little happiness bombs.
Like I always joke a joke about it.
Like my friend Duncan and I were we a
eight at this barbecue place and uh,
you know, a tip, the waiter a hundred
bucks and he didn't even know it.
But with laughs, thanks. Bye.
And I'm like, get out of there.
Like I love the fact that dude's going
to open up the thing and see a hundred
bucks, motherfucker just give me 100
bucks and you're gone mad and I'm gone.
So happiness bomb, you know, it's uh,
and I think that that sort of mentality,
I've also put that to stand up, you know,
and all of us would do that already does
that, Duncan does that. Brian does that.
Joey Diaz does that,
you know,
we're the first guys to tell you about
someone that we think is great and
someone that we'd love something
you should check out and uh,
it's aided all of us. You know what
you get, what'd you give you get back
10 times, right? That's a little bit,
yeah, I think so. Man. I've, you know,
there's a lot of comics who bring guys
on the road with them that are terrible
so they don't show them up.
I've always been of the mindset that I
should bring the funniest human beings
that are available so that the shows
better and it makes me laugh like I don't,
I'm not, it's not going to make me less
funny. Like that idea is crazy to me.
Like there's a lot of people that actually
want the person who's on in front of
them to not be funny because
then it makes them look better.
And I think that's that mean if you,
if that's the worst way of thinking ever.
Because that's your,
so your,
your sense of what it's funny or what's
funny about you is so delicate that no
one else can also be funny.
Like that's crazy.
Like sometimes you're funny but you're
only funny if someone before you sucks.
That doesn't even make sense. It's a
hold of the wrong mentality. Same thing.
It's a lack of that abundance mentality
and a lack of the real idea that human
beings are inexorably connected,
that we're connected by energy.
And that we're connected by intent and
then we're, we're connected by the,
the thoughts that we put out there and
the thoughts that we received from,
from other people. There's, it's
not, it's not this woo woo thing.
This is a real exchange of energy.
And I've been impressed by
the power of a conversation.
Like we get on on the air once a week
and we have an hour conversation with
someone who we think is important and
that's why we put them in the center of
the screen. We want to feature
these people to the world,
whether it's Simon Powell with a
siliciden solution or you know,
an MMA fighter or somebody and
say, check this dude out. But it's,
it's had a big effect on me.
I mean,
I've grown so much as a
person this last year,
it's probably been the best year of
my life and this is like 10 years in
financial markets and
making money and doing this.
But like this last year I've changed the
most I can drink Iowasca two years ago
I would have been the
dude that glazes over.
When you talk about psychedelics and
like, oh, you're one of those fucks. No,
and now I'm doing it. And like he
made you, what made you uh, have a,
an an altering of that idea? You know,
I walked away from that job because I,
I dunno, I think a lot of times as young
males were sold this kind of, this,
this capitalist promise, when you
go to school, you make the money,
you get the girl, you have the car
and you, and you're happy. And I'm a,
a lot of our viewers,
I ain't got the same way that like these
guys in their mid twenties that think
they're playing the game and they're
like, okay, then we're all my rewards.
And they're like, I'm not happy with
this anymore. And I think I got there,
I was doing this day in,
day out job and it was quote unquote
successful and I had all the trappings and
then I was just like, I wasn't
happy. So I just walked away from it.
Scared as hell wouldn't it with
nothing to do for six months.
I was like literally not doing much.
And Nick and I would meet in the west
end and walk around London for like three
hours and I was listening to your
podcast and we walk and we talk about
philosophy and women in finance and
perspectives. And at the end I'd be like,
nick, that would've made a fucking good
punk if we had just recorded it, you know?
And then Nick's like, let's do it.
Let's do it, let's do it. And then um,
there like arrived at Brian's house.
I thought it was going to be us like
talking into garageband and fines up this
huge studio and there's a microphone in
my face and that's awesome. It was cool.
And we got the cameras.
I thought the video was super important
because I listen to audio podcasts
before, but you need to seek guys
faces. And I always say for our guests,
people need to see at least the first
five minutes because they need to see if
their account or not or
if there are a Douche.
And you can tell after five minutes of
looking at someone, I think you can say,
okay, I like this guy's vibe. And
then you can listen if you want.
You can tell from listening to,
you know,
I was listening to the opiate Anthony
Show and there was a guy on, I was like,
man, this guy sounds like a cunt to
me. Like they're being nice to the guy,
but I'm like this guy sounds like a douche
bag. So I asked a friend and knew him.
He goes, oh, it's a piece of shit. I
go, oh thank you. I go cause I was like,
this guy is playing these guys.
I was like,
there's something about this
guy that is so disingenuous.
And as soon as I asked my friend, I knew
it was like, oh he's a piece of shit,
a fucking hate that guy. I was like, thank
you just by listening, by listening man.
But I agree with you about the video,
but the reality is the majority of our
listeners are audio only more than 70% I
think. Is it really 90%
yeah. We have a big butt.
I say I was more like 60% I'd say.
Well between Stitcher, which is,
are you guys on stage, isn't it?
It's cool. It's a cool service.
Don't tell bill burr.
Stitcher is a one,
one great way that we're distributed
through smart phones. But now there's the,
you know the iPhone
app on the new iPhones,
they have a podcast app and
we have our own podcast APP.
You can find the Joe Rogan experience
podcast APP. It's free. Um,
but the audio version is where people
like listen to it on the train or in their
car or the gym or whatever. I think
that's much more, more prevalent.
Very few assholes are sitting in
front of the computer watching.
I usually watch the first few minutes
just to take a look at the guests and then
I switched to audio. We got gifts by
the way. Might as well drop these guys,
these things on you guys. You have
gifts for us. How dare you. I know, huh?
Hopefully you brought batteries for you
and that's for you, right Ben? Oh, no way.
Brian,
did you say that with a gay accent?
You son of a bitch and that's
some crazy ass London real
now it's actually some posters.
I didn't have any wrapping
paper that going on at Sun.
We've got to get wrapping paper.
That's kind of cool, right?
Swabbed wrapping paper,
face mess. Come on dude.
You can put that up to the camp squad
wrapping paper. I'm telling Ya, this guy,
whoever you where that came
with the higher primate tattoo,
this guy had the dopest fucking one of
my tee shirt designs on his shoulder.
The Sheba one. Uh, he had it done on the
shoulder by this wicked tattoo artists,
whoever you were,
you've solved fucking son of a bitch.
That was a bad ass tattoo dude. You've
got pride gloves for me. He goes,
are some originals where
they used? No, that was uh,
I went to pride I think is no five
at Japan and never been used. So,
and then Robin's got the classic English
pride gloves are actually better,
better than the gloves that the
UFC uses in one way. Is that the,
the padding goes more over the end of
the fingers and it kind of keeps you
curled. I feel like there were less.
I pokes and pride. Do you feel that?
But I can remember. I don't remember
a single eye poking pride is awesome.
That was
fun. It was awesome. I still love it.
It's cool. It was such a crazy time.
Those fights were nuts,
man.
Like there's no other organization that
would have put on minute Toro versus Bob
Sapp. It was a great fight.
That was craziness, man.
I mean it was like they
were almost superheroes.
Don't know what we're talking about.
Minotauro is this guy who's like
the original Jujitsu heavyweight,
the original guy,
the first guy really to come along,
start submitting high end guys from
his back. Nobody did that before.
Minute Toro and he fought
this guy named Bob Sapp Bush.
Literally 370 pounds all muscle.
He was fucking ridiculous and it was a
crazy fight where Bob's sab pile drived
Minataro at one point in time,
Meta time was more than a hundred pounds
lighter than a more than a hundred I
think he's probably 150
pounds lighter than them.
It was craziness and he slapped the arm
by arm and arm bar at the end and caught
him in an arm bar. Spoiler
alert, sorry. As proper upset.
Probably couldn't extend his arm
more than that. So it was ridiculous.
Bob Sat was so big,
he didn't look real.
He made so much money in Japan
endorsing products and stuff.
He made millions of it then.
Yeah.
But then the market kind of fell
apart from what I understand.
We're going to get ensign
anyway on the podcast.
Last time instance in America
have him, yeah, he's great.
Went into Fukushima until the good stuff.
That was one intense dude.
That guy is the real
deal. And he uh, you know,
he was there during the whole,
like the height of pride and
he was also there when it,
when it dropped off.
So He'd probably be the one that could
tell you what the fuck really happened
when he comes on the podcast. Maybe we'll
get it from him. And James Thompson,
he was in involved as production, right?
Yeah, the Colossus. Yeah, he's on my,
met my message board now and he's,
uh, he writes a lot of blogs.
He's actually a very good writer.
Okay. Really interesting cat. You know,
cause he's this big scary
looking motherfucker but he's
actually a really wealth,
well thought out, well spoken guy. And
he sent us a message the other day,
he sent me Mr. Smith Facebook and I was
like, I can't be the same. James Thompson,
he's a great guy, man. Cool. Hi James,
I'm going to get back to you. Like I said,
he's on, he's on my message board
all the time. He's a great guy.
MMA guys are cool dudes. Yeah, it's,
I think it's along the same lines
when we talked about with Jujitsu.
The only difference with them and May
of course is that you have to consider
thank you very much for his gloves
by the way. You were awesome man.
You have to consider
with MMA, um, the, the,
the potential for longterm damage to your
mind. You just have to consider that.
And so these guys always have that
sort of hanging over their head.
And I think that's one of the reasons
why you really can't enjoy it.
Like you can enjoy Jujitsu, like
Jujitsu. Even when you, you,
you tap somebody,
you don't feel bad because you get
tapped to everybody taps you just,
just part of the whole game. It's
like he needs to learn that, you know,
you can't put your arm there if the
guy's a got your back and he's got the,
you know, he needs to learn what he did
wrong in that position because you see,
it's not like if you got
hydro in that position,
you've could have tapped him or you know,
you know what I mean?
It's like it's a lesson for everybody.
So you don't even feel bad
about delivering the lesson
because if you're trying
to get good at Jujitsu,
ultimately you should welcome getting
tapped because it exposes you.
You're your true weaknesses,
otherwise you're really not going to know.
And the only way to get better
is to see those weaknesses,
shore up those holes and move forward.
So someone who taps,
he was actually helping you. And that's,
that aspect doesn't exist in kickboxing,
kickboxing man.
You only have a certain ratatat tat that
you could take to your head. You only,
you'll have a certain number man.
And when you deliver,
especially when you deliver
on a sparring partner,
there's part of you that knows
that you just did some damage.
When you uncork a right hand on someone,
you see their eyes roll back in
their knees buckle. You know,
you just fucked that guy's consciousness
up for us to live smarter these days.
I know Mac,
Dan was here talking about that.
Do you think a lot of fighters have
had that new philosophy of I'm going to
train smarter, not harder. I think
some of them have certainly. Um,
but some of them don't have as a access
to the most tactical trainers. You know,
there's some trainers,
like there's this,
the Matt Hume's of the world who
have you watched their fighters.
There are fighters are so
obviously well trained,
very obviously technical Winkle.
John's fighters are also very similar.
Like you, there are super
obviously, well technically trained.
You Watch cowboy Cerrone
move, you know, you watch, um,
what Jon Jones is learning.
He's,
these guys are learning
very good technique and the
only way to truly do that is
to be taught by someone who
is at the front of the game.
Someone who really knows
what the fuck is up.
Someone who has a super technical
standup game and knows how to,
to move a fighter through progression,
challenged them and test them and, but,
but not have them get mall,
not have them get beat up and figure out
a way to balance all that out because
it takes one bad punch and like, yeah,
you'll never be the same fighter again.
Yeah.
I've seen guys that especially kicks,
I've seen guys that got kicked in the
head and we're never the same and that is,
that is 100% real, especially, um, like,
like there's certain kicks like wheel
kicks and things along those lines where
there's an insane amount of power. Like
if you look at Lens on your head, right?
Edson Barboza versus Terry Edom, fine.
We're, we're Edson Barboza Knock Terry at,
I'm out with the wheel kick in
Brazil. I mean, it was walkin nasty.
I mean the heel connected
right to the jaw,
the consciousness was gone instantly.
He fell down like he was dead.
Those kind of knockouts, man. How many
of those you got in your life? I mean,
do you have five?
Do you have a number?
Like five and after that you'll never be
the same person. Is it one? Is it two?
Is it three? We really don't know
because it varies per person.
Do you see these guys fade sometimes?
I mean,
you're in their weekend and week
out commentating as you have C's.
Do you ever see that? You know that Terry
Adam Guy and you're like, wait a second,
he's not moving in the same way.
He used to no question about it.
You could see it in their, their speech
patterns. Some guys, a lot of, you know,
look, the underground is a mixed
martial arts forum that I frequent. Uh,
mixed martial arts are com the best,
in my opinion,
the best mixed martial arts
website on the world. And uh,
shut up bitch. And one of, one
of the things, uh, have you been,
haven't been to share it.
They're good to their old school.
It's a great website too. There's
just a few too many cons on the board.
They're just a little better at
squashing. Cantinas I, although I here,
I shouldn't say that cause I hear shirt
docs gotten a lot better about it.
Anyway.
My point is like they're,
they're ruthless because they're hiding
behind an anonymous screen names,
but sometimes they're accurate and every
now and then they'll put up a video and
said, is, does so-and-so
seem to have brain damage?
And then you listen to when you're
like, wow, that guy is struggling.
Like there's certain,
like there was a video with Paul
Williams recently where he was, um,
you know Paul,
you'll Williams the boxer who got knocked
out by Sergio Martinez with vicious
one punch knockout.
And then he was in a motorcycle accident,
which left him paralyzed
and they interviewed him
in the motorcycle and I was
listening to his labored speech and I
was like, Ooh, that doesn't sound good.
So horrible man. Yeah, I met, I
would, while it didn't mean it,
but I was right behind
Terry Adams or a Terry.
I'm Norris rather when he was
talking to a fan once and uh,
I was a huge Terry Norris
fan when I was a kid.
He was like one of my favorite boxers
and Terry Norris was a standing there
talking to this dude and I
couldn't believe it was real.
I thought he was hammered drunk
or something. I thought they only,
this cannot be real.
This cannot be how this guy talks now.
And so I like inched over clothes and
listen to their conversation and oh my
God,
it was so sad.
It was the saddest fucking thing to me
because being a big fan of this guy and
watching his fight so many times, he
was, you know, this really wild dude.
And he, he got knocked out a few
times and he was one of those guys.
It was either, it was either he
would kill or be killed, you know,
and uh,
he got knocked out by some Badass dudes
like Julian Jackson knocked him out,
like fucking scary knockouts and to see
him when he was younger than me at the
time.
And to see him slurring his words like
that scared the fucking shit out of me,
man. Just scare the shit out of me.
You've seen Meldrick Taylor lately.
Have you seen that horrific,
horrific Meldrick Taylor was one
of the best boxers, you know,
to ever come out of the Olympics
and his early professional days,
he was fucking wizard.
He was so fast and he had one really,
really brutal fight with Julio.
Cesar Chavez. Never the same again.
And then Terry Norris knocked him out.
A few guys knocked him out,
but he's still fighting.
And they had an interview
with him recently on Hbo
when they showed him when he
was younger talking and then they
showed him today. And it's horrendous.
It's, it's, that is a real
reality of combat sports. Do you,
do you think the UFC is safe enough now
or do you think in 10 years we're going
to start seeing blow back? And is there
any way the other way around that, I mean,
humans want to see combat sports,
right? Well look, here's what safe.
You've got to get out before
you have irreparable damage.
That's what safe guys have done it.
There's guys who have retired and they're,
they're fine and healthy. Look,
Marvin Hagler is apparently in great,
great health and you know, he was a
great boxer but he never got knocked.
It never got fucked up,
you know,
and Hagler new after the sugar ray
Leonard fight. All right, I'm done.
Cause it never came back.
Rocky Marciano did the same thing,
got out before he got really fucked up.
[inaudible] was fine in his later years
before he died in a plane crash. But you,
you can figure out when,
but you have to be,
you have to be really smart and
it's hard to do. And it's also,
you have to have something that excites
you. Like fighting does cause these guys,
it's not like you can fight and all
sudden you can't fight anymore. It's,
you can fight and you fight just a
little less good than you used to and it
fucks with your head and you're like,
you know what man,
I just need to change my training up.
I need to incorporate some fucking
swimming or something. You know?
And you'll try to do that and then you
get knocked out again and you're like,
wow, I was winning that first
round until I got caught. You know?
And then then like Jens Pulver is
still going, still going at it.
And you guys still good enough to stay
in the game but only just only just,
and those, those knockouts,
those all become ticket wholes,
wholes in your ticket to chunk where
your ticket gets punched over and over
again. And how many you got? Who knows?
I mean Allister's has been stopped a
bunch of times, but you look at him now,
he's better than ever. Overeem. Yeah.
Over Ian's been stopped. But Peter Arts,
Peter Hertz has been
stopped a gang of times.
Still beat semis felt two years
ago in the k one Grand Prix.
So it's like some guys,
they can get stopped a bunch of times
and still be okay and other guys not.
And I don't have the drawer right at
the end of the day, no one can tell you,
no one can tell.
You know,
some guys like Mark Hunt can take
a fucking ferocious shot, you know?
And then there's other guys who just,
they can't take that much punishment.
They're built differently. They,
they, for whatever it's worth,
who knows what it is.
It was some person as a glass jaw,
the other guy's got an iron draw.
How much of it is psychological?
How much of it is physical? It's hard
to tell. It's a combination of both,
I'm sure. But it, it's not a
safe sport. It's, uh, it's,
it's safe as we can make it,
but the fighters all realize that there's
a certain amount of risk involved.
You're going to get injured,
you're going to get broken bones,
you're going to get torn ligaments
are going to get concussions.
You're going to have that in mixed
martial arts. There's no way around that.
So in that sense, it's as safe as we
can make it, but it's a dangerous sport.
So they have to think about that and
they have to train with that in mind and
they have to understand when it's time
to not do it anymore. Yeah, me off,
someone says, oh, the ref shouldn't
have stopped the fight. It's like, man,
always err on the side of caution
when it's someone's brain in jeopardy.
You know what I mean?
Uh, I think some guys,
you got to let them try to get at
like Frankie Edgar, perfect example.
How do you stop that guys? Flights early.
When you see like that first round back,
was it gray Maynard two fights in a row.
You see that and you go,
how could you stop that guys fight is you
gotta you gotta look at the individual
and his ability to bounce back from
punishment and you gotta get up.
Gotta give him the opportunity to win.
And Frankie's proven time and time again
that he can do that. So in that sense,
the referee has to be an expert in,
in fighters,
particular styles and their
ability to endure punishment.
It's not the best way to,
to compete.
But with a guy like Frankie Edgar,
it's also one of his weapons,
one of his weapons is that he's incredible
shape and that he recovers quickly
and you know,
he can wear a guy out because of that.
He can do drag a guy into
sub crazy fucking firefight
where you know he's got a
thousand bullets and the other guy
might only have 400 so you know,
he might think, oh, I've got 400 bullets,
this guy's fucking dead. Meanwhile,
he could keep going
man, and like, you know,
the fourth round with gray Maynard
when he knocked him out and it's like,
God damn,
he's still going.
He's still going at the same clip he
was going in the first round and gray
couldn't manage that at that
point and his in his career.
What's it like behind the scenes
at UFC? I mean, what, what would,
what would we be surprised at?
Something you just notice all the time
when you're calling those fights in the
UFC. I don't know man. You know, it's,
it's, it's a weird job. It's a weird,
it's a weird job. Even for me, it's
hard to believe that it is my job.
Like whenever I do it,
it's hard to believe.
I put on the headphones and they talked
to me in the booth. I'm like, what's up?
What's up? What's up? You're
ready to do this. Let's do this.
Goldie and I touched knuckles and the
first fight, we're going to start in five,
four tr charter, the music plays and
the lights go on. You're like, wow,
I guess this is my job.
It's not hard to imagine there.
They're paying you to do that even
seem real. It doesn't seem real.
It doesn't seem that I'm the one
who's, who represents the, the,
the, the techniques and I'm the one who
explains to people what to look for and
what's going on. It's, it's very
strange. So even while I'm doing it,
I'm doing it to the best of my abilities.
And the best of my knowledge,
it's still bizarre is fuck,
I have a hard time believing it's
really happening while I'm doing it.
I always tell people were like you
and Goldberg, like I'm the Goldberg.
Cause like I got a bunch of questions.
I gotta ask Hancock for example.
And then Nick's kind of like the
play by play flow. He just like,
if he's feeling something, he just asked
that question and then I'm like, okay,
I gotta get to these things.
I got to say the fighter does this,
it does this next week on Fox, you
can watch this show. Yeah, yeah.
That's Goldberg's move. Yeah,
it's, it's a difficult job.
He doesn't get nearly as much credit as
he deserves. He's really good at that.
He's really smooth. People just get
upset that he's not a martial artist.
But the bottom line is you really have
to be an actual martial artist to do
martial arts commentary. There is
no way around it. You can't fake it.
You can't not know how to take someone's
back and explain how he's got to take
us back. You can't, if you see someone
who's doing something, you know what?
I'll see someone occasionally, I'm like,
you can't let go of that under hook.
I'm like, if this guy, let's
go with that under hook,
this motherfucker is going to
take us back. Like especially
a guy like honey, ya,
ya or someone is like a super high
level guy like honey. Yah, Yah.
One of his recent fights,
he got site control on this guy and as
soon as he reached back, I'm like, oh,
he's going north south choke.
And I called it like several steps ahead.
But with a god like honey, you can
see it like I know what he's gonna do.
You can't let him wrap his arm around
your neck and you let him reach back with
that left arm.
You might as well just go to sleep and
just take a nap cause he's gonna choke
you. And that's step one
of a three step process.
You're not gonna be able to stop
because once he got step one,
he's he's basis set and
you're done and you know you,
you got to know that there's no way
you can know that without doing that.
Listen to the early or the
commentary in the early year of CS.
It's hysterical because these guys were
like boxing commentators and something
that they just had no idea.
Right. You got it. You got to,
the hardest part to me is the ground
game because there's so much varied.
There's a lot of variables
in standup for sure. There's,
it's not that standup is easy,
but there's infinite variables
on the ground and you have
to understand the, the,
the various different styles of
attacking different positions.
Like everybody's got
there at like some guys,
they'll go side control on a guy and
face towards the feet and they'll,
they'll be like,
guys will try to get a gun at twister
or tried to get someone's back.
And then there's other guys that go judo
style and they're going to look for,
you know, the, the, the mounted crucifix.
They're going to look to ground and pound
or they're going to look for a scarf
whole or some, some kind of
like mark home. Mark Coleman
did that to Dan Severen.
It was like when the first submissions
in the UFC heavyweight division,
when he won the title, you, you,
you, you have to see all those,
you have to understand those, you have
to have been strangled. You have to,
you have to get somebody with it. You
have to fight it off. You have to.
If you don't,
you're not going to be able to explain
to people what this guy's doing wrong or
what he needs to do or what. And that's
what makes it more exciting when,
when a guy is doing,
like Jimmy Smith is really good at
it from Bella tour with Jimmy Smith,
if a guy's got someone's
back, he's like, he's got,
he's got to defend with his right arm
while he's attacking with his leg,
you know, he'll, he'll explain to
people and if you're a person who's a,
an amateur or someone who has
nothing to do with martial arts,
you can watch it and fall on, oh, I
see what that guy's doing. He's right.
He's going to choke that guy. Oh
yeah. Yeah. And the other guy,
he's saying he's got out,
got to get his leg Frey,
otherwise it's going to
get you. Oh, I see. Yeah.
He's holding him with his legs and
it, it, it, it adds to the excitement.
And that's,
you can't be a sports guy and do that.
You have to be a martial
artist. And that note, Joe,
what's your favorite submission?
Chokes the color or no, no,
no, no, no, no. I hate that.
I do. Yeah. I have a black
belt under John Jackson Hole,
but I don't fucking use it.
I use over hooks and under hooks.
I,
I believe that if your
game is gay oriented, the,
the good thing about the gies defense,
the good thing about the Biggie is
you must be tactical in your defense.
You have to be tactical in your tax
can't because a guy gets a hold of your
collar or a guy gets
a hold of your sleeve.
There's a lot of shit they could do
to you. We, if you were slippery,
and with Nokia you can
just muscle out of it,
but you have to use technique and you
have to do it the right way with a g.
So in that way, looking at good, you're
like a doss and Bravo. But I think that,
um,
or rear nakeds and gay teens.
But I think that the beautiful thing about
a g is if you're fighting a guy who's
got a coat on,
you know some guys got a leather
jacket on who's talking shit like,
oh you have to do is grab his collar
and he's dead and what's happening?
All you have to do is get a hand.
He won't even know what you're doing.
He'll be trying to punch you and
you just reach into his college.
You know what I find interesting,
I'm an,
I don't know if you remember
there was that scientists,
there was a a group of islands that had
different monkey tribes on and what was
happening is when one monk in
one on and learn one, learn
how to pick a certain Manana,
we'll open a certain fruit.
Then all the other monkeys learned it
and it's a similar thing with Jujitsu,
like suddenly like you'll just see this
new choke in the game that you've never
seen before and then in three
months everyone knows it.
It's such an interesting thing.
Darcy's came along now way that's made
me think of it kick that Anderson Silva
Front kick after they started doing
everybody. Well that was so dramatic.
That was something that everybody saw.
But what I think what you're saying
is that it's just like spreads through
schools because people just figure it
out at the same time because they watched
you two photos
sometimes.
Well there's also one technique,
like there'll be like a new technique
that like one of them was attacking from
the half guard.
One of the things that opened up the Darce
was at a lot of people were attacking
from the half guard and they were
going with a double underhooks attack.
And when they're going with
a double under hooks attack,
a lot of guys were sneaking their arms
in and then all of a sudden it became
Anaconda, chokes, Doris chokes. It became,
that's what people were going for it
because you subset of God basically. Yeah.
And it was basically to, to deal with
under hooks that a guy, you know, if,
so if you're in a guys,
you're on the side of a guy,
like maybe in half guard and a guy's like
has a really strong under hook. If you,
you know that if you get your arm under
his under hook and passes neck and
connect your arms together,
now he's in a bit of trouble.
You just put yourself in
a dangerous situation.
Like you're trying to be very offensive
budding, allowing me to wizard,
you're underhooking pass by your neck,
now you've allowed me to control your
neck, now I've got a position on you.
And now especially if
you go Japanese Necktie,
which is one of the new moves that a
lot of guys are doing now and said,
I've never even heard of that and we're
got to show it to you as the shit.
He's way more high.
It's way more percentage,
way more high percentage than a,
than a Doris.
Let me ask your question cause you control
the guy's head check question about
London and, and what you think of London.
Well, he, I think he was going to,
I was cut him off on the
show. I'm always like, no,
it's hard to do that right here. We have
an hour. You're rude to like, to like, uh,
you know, to cut people off, but
you know, you're not meaning to,
it's just like you have a thought and
if you don't say come on down to the
scapes and it gets away from you.
Cause the conversation derivatives I have,
I have, I have two dude. I'm sorry. I'll
never forgive myself. So the first one is,
um,
do you think if you go to a time machine
and traveled a hundred years into the
future and then walk
into a Jujitsu Academy,
do you think you'd still be able to hang?
Like I'd get killed? Do you think so?
I'm pretty sure. My interesting.
Yeah. Unless, unless a,
they were fucking terrible like fuck
ups from white belts. Yeah, I guess so.
But I think black belts, well, black
belts, they're really good black belts.
I'm not, you know, I'm a week black
belt, like objectively, like I'm strong,
don't get me wrong,
I'm a have strong Jujitsu.
But as far as like high end black belt
guys, I used to get tapped, you know,
it's just, it's just reality. You
know, I'm not a world champion.
I remember the time to put into that too.
In order. I have much more potential.
I mean, if I really had the time to train
five days a week and get a strength and
conditioning, I think I could
jump my game up big. I think my,
my mind is way more ahead of my body.
It's just, I don't have the time to do it.
I don't know when it's
time to put in the numbers
in between having a
family and doing standup,
doing a podcast and traveling for the UFC,
it's hard to try to train as much
as I can. And when I train, I do.
I give 100% but he's still
writing a book or, yeah. Yeah.
I just got to do you feel like you need
to get a book out of, you know, um,
I would like to do it.
I have a,
I have a lot of shit already written
and I will eventually put it out.
But right now I'm concentrating on
my new studio and my standup special,
which is going to be out at the end
of the month and the end of October.
Is that already in the can? It's,
yeah, it's already in the can.
It's just a matter of the
website getting built, which is,
it takes a lot longer than you
think to have a nice website made.
So that's being made. And then, um,
just to get the infrastructure
in place to share it. It, I,
I found out somewhere along the line that
when I do too many things at the same
time, I don't have any fun
and joy. Everything suffers.
A family and everything.
Yeah.
Well I won't let that suffer.
So the things that suffer or
other aspects of my career,
so I limit the amount of shit that I do.
So once this standup specials out
and I can not think about that, boom.
Then I'm diving full into writing.
I'm writing the book
because I already have the,
I have to balance it out
with writing standup,
which right now is more important because
my special is about to drop and I have
a whole new hour that I've basically
put together between the time I did the
special and now what do you want from
your stand up like in five years from now?
I mean do you want to see like bigger
audiences or do you ever have goals like
that? No, no. I'm, I'm super
happy with the way. If,
if nothing changed at all then the
other than the way it is right now.
If it just maintained a,
I'd be the happiest person on earth.
I have the greatest audiences in the
history of that. The the art form.
It's the craziest thing ever.
I wish you guys could come to see some
of these crowds because they're crazy and
it's mostly podcast fans.
It's mostly people who don't just
resonate with the idea of comedy,
but resonate with the idea that there's
someone out there that's also confused
by all this and there's someone out
there that's being honest about all of it
and those people. I've,
I've, I've sort of found a,
found a huge amount of them because
of this podcast and I don't,
I don't desire anything more than that.
It's already the,
just having all the people
come up to me after shows.
All the people that tell me they've lost
weight and all the people that told me
they've got their shit together,
that they've,
they're living their life like
they're the hero in their own story.
It's a great way,
and it should be like the blockbuster
moment in the movie every day.
You should be saving the
girl. You shouldn't be that.
You could, you could be,
you could literally do what the hero
would do, you know? And it doesn't mean,
you know, rescue babies had a burning
buildings. It means don't be a cunt.
Figured out a way to get
your shit together. Don't,
don't be someone who's just slacking off
and jerking off while behind you is a
mountain of work to do, you know, get,
get, get your stuff done, do it. Do it.
Do be someone who you admire.
And that's something that I,
I had to learn on my own slowly
over a long period of time.
But in reiterating that on the podcast,
just like in teaching Jujitsu,
it's become like very concrete in my head.
You know,
I'm have another very deep and meaningful
question of I want your input on it.
In fact, me and my Jujitsu buddies
debate about the solar, the time,
and some of them want your,
your, your input, which is, um,
what do you think would win in a fight
out of a silverback gorilla and a bangle?
Tiger, tiger, tiger themselves.
Show that gorilla. Come on man.
See I say gorilla man. He can rip a car,
tire and half with his bare hands. Right?
That shit with that Tiger's got your
back and choking giant. I refuse.
I don't think the tiger would fuck with
the gorilla because it's not going to be
easy. I think it's going to be a struggle.
That's why gorillas nest on the ground,
you know,
gorillas don't give a fuck.
They're there 500 pounds and they're
five foot four natural predators. They,
they're so strong. I mean, we can't even
wrap our heads around how strongly are,
because chimps are strong as fuck.
And gorillas would rape a chimp with
their little one inch Dick. You know,
gorillas have tiny decks and know
that because they're so dominant,
they don't have any pressure
from other males. And the women,
the female gorillas are so in line
with how everything's supposed to be.
They're not sluts at all.
Female chimps are whores.
They will fuck anybody comes
around and mail chimp's know this.
Some mail chimps have giant testicles.
And the reason why they
have giant testicles is they
always gotta be ready to go
with a big fat load for
one of these dirty bitches.
That's a part of the show that's
a part of the chimp world.
All animals that live in
promiscuous societies, all,
they all have large testicles,
including human beings.
There's a direct correlation between
the size of a man's testicles.
And the promise cues.
You have the women in your environment.
When you going to Africa on Safari,
I know you always said you're scared
of Africa. This is a real safari dude.
You Go Botswana. Yeah, but
you know when you go dude,
you go to these wildlife
sort of containment areas
where you know everybody gets
in Africa,
you can go to propose Botswana,
you can go by line.
There was a whole fucking story recently
about a these two female lions that
broke into a house and pulled a guy
out of the shower. He was showering,
he was naked, showering and he got
killed by two female. Let's do all that.
They do all the hunting and nails.
Just sit around.
Could you wrap your head around
it so you're not trying to Africa.
So He da,
he da and you hear something.
You open the fucking curtain. There's
two lions in the bathroom with you,
two female lions and they just
put the beaten on you, sign,
rip you to shreds and drag you out.
Okay, what's the best way to go? Africa.
Africa can suck my Dick.
Okay.
I'm not going to wear all
the scary animals live bears.
So Joe, if you have to choose a way to
die, like would you rather be in the,
in the water with a great white
or no, you're not going to want,
if me into a fucking heart attack.
I'm fucking scared of all
of them, man. I'm scared of
tigers. I'm scared of sharks.
I'm scared of everything dude. Sound
scared of all that shit, Joe, by the way,
that the ancient alien documentary,
amazing thing that you tweeted talk.
Did you watch the whole thing? I watched,
I watched all three hours. Yeah, I should.
I should give that guy
props. Um, there's a,
a video that I tweeted yesterday,
today is October the second
and if you go to the October,
the first feed,
I tweeted this video where this guy,
he must have like massive autism because
this guy went and debunked every single
point that ancient aliens has ever put
forth about how humans could have never
built this.
This is impossible.
He fucking stomped a dirty mud hole in
every fucking show that they've ever
done. And he did it. It's
over three hours long.
It's on youtube and there's no question,
no question, no question. And you're like,
okay, yeah, it's so good. It said,
just go to ancient aliens debunked
and you want full movie fixed audio.
That's the version. The other one had
a little weird glitch in the audio,
but it's still, it's still, you can
still watch it. It's still excellent.
And it's called the guy's
youtube name is what does it,
verse by verse bt.
That's it.
It's one word verse by verse bt that his,
his uh,
his youtube page and it's a brilliant job.
Whoever this guy is,
thank you very much.
Because what you did is you cleared up
so much confusion and for me there was a
lot of stuff that I
really didn't understand.
There's still some stuff that
hasn't been explained. There's a,
some of the things about Puma
Puma coup and the way they, uh,
they move stones and fit them in.
I think it's very
interesting that you know,
that this guy was able to find so many
pieces of evidence that point to how they
did certain things and explain how they
built obelisks and giant stones and,
and show ones that were in the process
of being made when they abandoned.
So you can clearly see how they did it.
Fascinating.
And also yet some brilliant insight on
the construction of the pyramids that I
had never heard before about the
theory of the internal ramp because the
question has always been like how they,
how they placed the stones,
how did they move them into place? And
uh, they actually did some sort of a, um,
uh, like an x ray of the, uh,
with some radio wave graph of the pyramid
and you can actually see the internal
ramp and they didn't understand what
that was when they first made this, uh,
this reading of the,
the actual structure of the pyramid of
Giza until this internal ramp theory came
into play.
And this guy examines the internal ramp
theory and shows all the evidence for it,
including areas of the pyramid where at
certain points you could actually go in
through the side of the pyramid,
there's a hole and you can go in and see
where there's all this space in there
and most likely that's how it was built.
What does Graham Hancock saying?
That's what I want to know. Either way
this, listen, listen, this, this, um,
ancient aliens debunking.
What it does is explain how all
these things were done. Would,
it doesn't explain is how
they figured this out. Would,
it doesn't explain is what kind of
intense mathematics were involved in the
equations of 2 million,
300,000 stones each.
What each of them cut so perfectly that
they meet exactly in a point at the top.
It's amazing. I mean when it doesn't
explain why they did these things,
it doesn't explain that and it doesn't
explain where they got the knowledge from.
It explains how they did it and how
they did it was, it was certainly,
it took a long time.
It certainly was incredibly difficult
and certainly required master craftsmen
and builders and skillful labor.
But the knowledge to construct it is,
which really fascinating because that
is what Graham Hancock points to is that
is not that he doesn't believe that this
was a like aliens came down and gave
people information like
the ancient aliens guys do.
What he believes is what's
bad backed by real evidence.
And that evidence is that there was a
very sophisticated culture that existed
all over the world,
somewhere around 10,000 BC.
And that's something probably
happened to those people.
And we had to start a
lot of things over again.
And coincidentally this time period
that Graham Hancock points too,
which is about 10,000 plus BC,
is the exact same time period that the
most recent discoveries of glass impact
glass from meteor showers
has been discovered at the
same layer of dirt all over
the world.
So scientists are absolutely convinced,
and this is fairly recently,
that there was incredibly destructive
meteor showers around 12,000 years ago and
they found these in France.
They found this glass in the Middle
East and when they do soil samples,
it's all on the same,
I believe it's called the same Strada.
I think that's how they describe it.
The same area where they know, you know,
they're the way to do the calculation
stuff, how, how old it is.
And when they do a carbon testing on
that area and they believe that somewhere
12,000 years ago, that's when the
ending the, and the ice age ended.
That's when all this mass extinction,
it's all around the same time of
woolly mammoths and Saber Tooth Tigers.
It's all on the same sort of area.
Um,
and they could all be
v could all coincide.
So what we have in ancient Egypt is not
simply an amazing culture that in 2,500
BC built the pyramids.
It might very well be that 10,000 BC
they built the Sphinx and 10,000 BC,
they had massive stone
structures already in place.
Back when we thought that people were
just hunter gatherers. That's this,
that's the basis of Graham
Hancock's thoughts on it.
And every day he's being proven correct.
The more people discover
about ancient civilizations,
the more Graham Hancock is
correct. We have a, sure we
were an all of the amazing,
just a lovely human being to just a great
guy, you know, just exudes it, you know,
he's like the perfect representative in
my opinion of what can be accomplished
through psychedelics and
thinking and, and, and just his,
his take on his own work and his
take on, you know, the, the, the,
the difficulty in trying to express
these very controversial ideas.
It's amazing to be honest, I don't know
if you've watched the show with us,
but he talked about the 24 years that he
was smoke cannabis and how the Iowasca
told him and he just dropped that right
on us and the episode and just like, man,
I have a lot of respect for someone who
can just be that honest about themselves.
That's the kind of guy you want
running your country men. I just, yeah,
he's no longer a writer or
an archeologist. He was like
a, it was a great match.
Mine is a great man and he changed
the way I looked at history.
That book fingerprints of the Gods
changed the way I look at history and I'm
pretty convinced now,
especially due to the most recent
geological evidence and to discoveries of
things like to go Beckley Tempe,
which is this 14,000 year old massive
compound of huge nine foot tall stone
columns.
This is really an excuse.
It's a 19 I think it might be
19 foot tall stone columns,
but what it is still amazing
because 14,000 years ago
people were supposed to be
hunter gathering. It wasn't supposed to
be any sort of civilization like this.
We're supposed to live in fucking
teepees and Shit, you know?
Then he's showing that there's these
huge stone structures by the way,
which they've only uncovered
less than 4% of I believe,
because it's a painstaking process of
uncovering because you know they've got to
do it with toothbrushes and shit.
They've got a sift through the sand
and find bone fragments and pottery
fragments and things along those lines.
But what they do know about gold Beckley
Tempe is that it was covered up 14,000
years ago. Covered up,
purposely covered up.
They literally buried
a whole fucking city,
14,000 originally made intentionally.
They did intentionally.
They know they did because the
type of landfill that they use,
the type they used a type of, they filled
in the area. They're convinced of this.
They've, you know, I don't know
how they can figure that out,
but they were pretty much in
agreement go to those sites. I mean,
you don't want to go to the pyramids.
And Chuck been to teaching Eatsa.
That's the only place I've ever been
to South America. Mexico, Mexico. Yeah.
It's near Cancun. Fucking amazing
man. It's amazing. It's incredible.
It's feels,
feels different when you're there.
You can feel there's something
about it Reiki beyond freaky.
Just to think that you're walking in
this area. And as I'm looking around,
I remember she was standing there,
um,
and just thinking that at one
point in time this was like,
this was a football field and they were
playing that crazy game where they kick
this ball through a hole which devolve to,
uh,
they believe that they might have played
it with human heads at one point in
time. And just the one
area where they have, uh,
the sacrificial altar where they would
kill someone and cut their heart out and
throw the heart down the stairs. I
mean, they had it, you could go there,
you could touch that altar,
you could walk up this stone staircase.
There's a few really negative when
you're like, feels, it's like they,
these guys went dark.
Hancock's new book is about as new
fictional pieces about that whole period.
And he said, oh my gosh,
she's talked about it on the
show. And we were like, yeah,
it talks about 80,000 people being
slaughtered in four days for ceremonial
purposes. And he was, I was just
like, Oh God. I was terrified.
He was actually at paypal, they
slaughtered in four days. And he said,
just the rivers of blood and
that the human sacrifice,
I guess they would fatten people up in
pens for days and weeks on end in order
to sacrifice for like a brand new monument
and just the concept of you being,
they're fattened up with your family
when you know you're just going to be,
have just db used to have your heart
pulled out of your body and the shown and
then human beings are capable
of some fucked up shit.
And the crazy thing is it's like how
did they go from the people that were so
incredibly sophisticated that they built
these structures that were aligned to
the cosmos and when they were
aligned to the directly correlate,
a lot of them do with constellations.
Like they understood the
alignment of certain stars.
They understood the prediction of lunar
eclipses like a thousand years in the
future.
They had figured out.
So they had this incredible
knowledge of astronomy and they,
they had figured out and recorded a
lot of like really incredible shit.
And yet they were killing 80,000 fucking
people and a couple of days and light
and dark boys go together. Right.
Is that what it is? I mean is,
I feel like it's, I, I've been talking
about this lately on stage too,
about the real problem with the nuclear
bombs at the guy who pressed the button,
never didn't build it, doesn't
understand it, didn't create it,
didn't invent nuclear explosions,
didn't figure out how to split the atom,
didn't construct the whole piece.
He does it.
He's come along and presses this button,
almost Oppenheimer who worked on them
and it hadn't project in New Mexico.
He was, had big moral dilemmas about
creating the atom bomb. I mean,
and he later died from cancer,
I think it was from throat cancer,
from being radio acted
when he was working on it.
But he was really troubled his whole life.
Yeah.
Well do you remember what he said?
He said when they tested
the first nuclear bomb,
the very first explosion he quoted
the Bhagavad Gita said, I am,
I am become death destroyer of worlds.
So he said like at the first,
cause he knew what he had
done. He's like, Oh shit,
he's got up some since calm one.
Could it just slacked off for probably
a few nights of work and not created it?
Well,
see the thing who,
the people who can create it would
not be the people who created it.
The people who can create it with a
few people that go, you know, if you,
if you just understand how atoms work,
if you've got in there and split this
and did this and that, you could do,
you shouldn't do it,
but if you did,
well you could do is to puck and have
the incredible destructive power.
Don't do it. But if you wanted to
do it, that's what you would do.
It's like the warrior or the the general,
the military man who would drop a fucking
atomic bomb on a building on a city is
way too fucking stupid to ever
figure out how to make that thing.
It's like the mentality to figure out
how to make an atomic is completely
different than the fatality that you would
just drop one out of a plane that's a
different job.
If he had a nuclear bomb,
would would launch it on Israel or do
you think even augmented, God knows,
I don't want to be the guy that
does this disruptive. I think.
I think that when you have nuclear power
or any sort of mass destructive power,
it's a lot like the military
equivalent of winning the lottery.
You didn't really earn that.
You just have it.
You just have it and you're
going to spend it and you,
you're going to spend it with no regard.
You're going to spend it and not knowing
the consequences. You're, you're,
you're a child with a grownup toy.
You, you haven't developed this thing.
You've just,
you've just got access to it the same way.
Some asshole who doesn't really understand
cars can somehow or another just go
into a Chevy dealership and buy a corvette
Zr one with 648 horsepower and just
fucking stomp on it and
slam it right into a tree.
That moron should have never had access
to that kind of power or never have
access to that kind of ability to move
so quickly with his own decision making.
He can decide whether or not to run the
red lights and whether or not to just
drive his car right into a fucking mall
parking lot and smash into cars. You can,
you can do anything you want when
you have a a corvette, you die.
But if you could choose to just drive
into traffic if you're fucking crazy.
There's something weird
about our ability in,
in contrast to what we
understand or what we've earned,
the power that we've earned. Like
if you build a bow and Arrow, okay,
if you're a tribesmen, you're out there
in the woods, you build a bone hour,
you craft it and you develop your aim
and then you use it and you hunt and kill
an animal. I mean, that is, that's
fair trade. I mean, you've really like,
you've earned all of those steps.
You've vasculature and all of those,
but if you drop a nuclear bomb in a
lake and then start pulling out fish,
we've got all the fish we need.
You know,
you're just some fucking asshole
when the nuclear bomb like you, you,
you can't build one of those on your own.
On a similar note, like that's why, um,
I've been told the best, the best,
uh, war leaders are the best.
Generals are the ones who've come up
through the ranks because they've seen
combat. They know what it means
to send people onto a battlefield.
Where's the guy who just went to west
point and never fired a shot in his life?
It's easy for him to say like,
send in the troops because he doesn't
know the direct consequences of that.
Right.
I think that's one of the reasons why
they like people that get into office that
aren't like Wesley Clark or like
John Mccain, people that, that,
you know, essentially their chicken
hawks, guys like George Bush,
guys like Dick Cheney,
the ones who are the biggest warmongers.
So the ones who never experienced
it personally, you know,
I think a guy like John Mccain would
be far more reluctant to use a military
strategy knowing that there's
boys out there that it could,
it could have been just like him,
you know,
a guy like a guy like Wesley Clark was
Cerner certainly be far more reluctant to
take, uh, you
know,
the lives of these young soldiers for
granted because at one point in time that
was him.
Colin Powell was really good about that
in the first Iraqi invasion because he
had spent so long in Vietnam and he'd
seen the mission creep there and like have
it lasted forever and ever and
he was really adamant. It's just,
let's go in and get the hell
out. What's mission creep, Brian?
It's when you don't have a defined, uh,
outcome of a mission, you were not like,
we're going to go in and do x, y, and zed.
We're going to go in and wait until
there's peace or we're going to defeat
terrorism. And it's like there's no,
there's no specific, uh, and to that,
to that mission that's
happening in Afghanistan, it's
happened in Iraq and yeah.
Yeah. That's the idea that
we're slowly and, you know,
empowering our basis out
there and building up.
And that's what we're doing
right now with Iran. You know,
what we're doing with Iran, those are
slowly moving battleships into that area.
And you know, it's, it's getting pretty
scary events. A crazy unique case.
There's a website I want you to check out
some time called strapped for.com STI,
e t, f, O, r. And they're really big
into this thing called geopolitics,
which is basically every nation is built
on kind of their geography as well.
And they just talk about how it racks
built up in a very mountainous way.
And it's in no one's interest to go in
there cause it's such a mess to do that.
And I hope we don't anyways cause we
don't really have any business doing that.
Uh, no. Sorry. Ran. Yeah, of course
I ran. Yeah. Yeah. It's crazy.
We don't have business doing it.
It's nuts.
They certainly shouldn't develop nuclear
arms. Who knows if they even are,
who knows what they're even, they
even are trying, you know, it, it, I,
I assume they probably are,
but it could be propaganda.
It could be just one of those things
where we just need that, that area,
that path to bring our oil
through. You know? And that's what,
that's what supposedly what this
whole fucking thing is about.
And it's a great Trump card.
I mean North Korea has used this threat
of a nuclear device to keep them alive
for like 20 years and they
keep bargaining. They're like,
we're going to bargain this month.
And then they don't.
And but it's kept him kind of
relevant just having this one weapon.
So I think that's why countries want it.
The whole world's a mess.
I mean it's a bit frustrating
and we've more podcasts.
Yeah, well believe it or not, that
sounds stupid, right? Like boy,
how grandiose are way we think
we're going to change the world.
The only way you can change the world
is to influence young people so that the
young people go through the ranks,
don't imitate all the crusty old fuck
heads that had been running things and
these archaic ways because that's just
the way things always were done and
communication is super
important. Communication and
access to information. It was,
this is a different world.
This is not a world where you can
bullshit people quite as easily.
Like if your idea is we're going to the
Iranian public and they listen to your
podcast and similarly maybe if there was
a crazy uranium podcasts and we could
listen to their leaders,
I just think communicating would get us
at least in the right direction. Well,
I bet my podcast does reach a lot of
our rains and I bet there's a lot of
Iranians who have their own podcast
just like London Real, you know?
I think I got to assume that,
that this is not going to stop here.
This well. I think what's going
on with podcasts and with,
especially with the,
just the free ability to distribute
information and to communicate,
not even distribute information,
but just even a talk on
the Internet to discuss things,
to do review things.
It's never existed like this before.
There's never been a time in human history
where a guy could be doing something
like my podcast in La and you guys in
London could be listening to it when
you're going jogging.
I mean with her,
where the fuck is that better part emails
from people in Denmark then we Taiwan
to, yeah, and it's five years ago
we could have done that. It's cheap.
It's not hard to do.
It's not like we had to spend billions
of dollars and put satellites in orbit
and figured out how to,
you know,
figure out how to get our
message to people and goes
over on a fucking horseback
and you know, you gotta,
you gotta decipher it.
You gotta hire a local guy who
speaks to the Lang. No, it's, it's,
it's fucking easy as shit,
man.
It's really easy and this is not
going to change. I think that,
I know what the crazy thing is,
is the Internet was originally the
Department of Defense Project and now it's
going to, it's going to bite
them in the air, but it's not,
it's still,
we need them still.
We just don't need them as a daddy.
Okay. No Man needs another man.
As a fucking Daddy, you know, what we
need is camaraderie and we need community.
We need the government to rethink what
they really are. They are one of us there.
We're all in this together.
It's not like the Stanford prison
studies where they, you know,
took college kids and they had,
some of them become guards and someone
become prisoners and he immediately see
corruption and abuse. It doesn't have to
be prisoners and guards. It shouldn't be,
but that's what it is.
We have a government that's set up
that's not a part of our community.
That's not one of us.
We have instead people that are trying
to tell us what to do or the or,
we'll lock you up and they suck
at what they do. They suck.
They're incompetent and they're shitty
at their job. So they like to hide.
They'll like to hide information.
They'd like to make it really hard for
you to get ahold of anything that shows
that they suck at their job and when
you bust them suck at their job and you
need to distribute that information,
you become an enemy of the state.
Like wikileaks. I mean stop and
think about what we cause has done.
Wiki leaks in releasing that
collateral murder video.
Let people know how calloused war can
make regular good Americans and turn
soldiers into people that don't care.
Don't care that innocent people got
gunned down in the street and that make
jokes and talk lightly about machine
gunning vans filled with people,
including children. I mean this is,
this is fact. You watch that video,
it makes you feel bad for
the guys who are shooting.
It makes you feel bad for
the people on the ground.
The whole thing makes you feel bad
because the whole thing is just off.
It's just wrong and crazy
and not what we want.
When we think about the United
States of America in a proud way,
we think of ourselves as being
the, you know, a noble country,
a country filled with people that uh,
are rugged individual is that figured
out a way to escape from the monarchy of
England and come over
here and do it on our own.
And this time we're going to
have freedom and we're going to,
we're going to have the constitution and
we're going to make sure that we have
rules in place so
the corruption can, and then you see
just massive amounts of corruption.
Where there 40, 50 years ago, I mean,
we had a guest, well, we had the, okay,
I guess we had a guest on two weeks
ago and we talked about Islam.
He's a Muslim guy who lives in
Britain. He's from Pakistan,
and he was like, Brian,
when I grew up in the early
eighties late seventies I was like,
we had all these wonderful ideas of
what the u s it was something good.
Maybe we were also anti-soviet
at the time, I don't know,
also didn't have the Internet. That's
a big part of it that we didn't know.
No one knew about it, didn't know what
we were doing. Operation Northwoods man,
that was in the 1960s in the 1960s they
were going to blow up airplanes and they
were going to throw a bombs and attack
a Guantanamo Bay and they were going to
blame it on Cubans. So we'd go to war
with Cuba and that's a, that's a fact.
The freedom of Information Act
has released all the documents.
It wasn't a pipe dream. It was
signed by the Joint Chiefs of Staff,
but do we have a less favorable
view globally now American
than say 30 years ago?
Yes, because of the Internet
and because of the Iraq war,
the Iraq war and Afghanistan
and the subsequent damage.
And then of course in other countries with
the drone attacks, you know, and look,
I don't know how much of a threat alcaide
it is. I don't understand. I'm not,
I'm not privy to that information. They
don't let us, you know, we're not a,
we don't get access to Todd.
I don't know how many different
attacks on America they've,
they've caught it at a second successful
attack since nine 11 which is crazy.
It's crazy.
But it's also crazy that anybody
wants to attack us in the first place.
Why they met and would George Bush
the only nonsense we ever got us,
they hate our freedom. And
you're like, you motherfucker.
That's it. That doesn't a,
it doesn't. I always wonder if
America as a sovereign entity,
if it was actually attacked,
which has never really been on its own
soil except for nine 11 but that was okay
to building. All right, Hawaii.
All right guys, you're killing me.
What everyone von together
or is that you said earlier,
is it a nation that's not,
that's fragmented. I mean,
if the way is Louisiana got attack
would be la people feel like,
well fuck you guys.
Or would you get drafted and sign your
kids up to go and die to defend those
borders?
Well,
after nine 11 what happened here was
everywhere you go you would see flags,
American flags,
like within the first couple months after
nine 11 everyone's car had a flag on
Manhattan too. I was
there. It was nuts, man.
Especially in New York where everyone's
an asshole. Yeah. Can you talk about it?
Cause it's the one place
where people are just,
but they were friendly all of a sudden.
Weird in a creepy way. It was weird.
It was real weird.
I remember going to New York,
we went maybe a year after September
11th and it was still like reverberating.
It was the ripples and aftershocks of
nine 11 people were way nicer than they'd
ever been before. Way more
friendly way, way more humble,
way more respectful for law
enforcement and firefighters.
They were really respectful,
but it's not human.
Fred on the global scale for us to
pull together as a species. You know,
maybe an asteroid does need to hit the
earth and a quarter of the population has
to die so we all go fuck and hell,
we need each other.
We got to stop being
con through each other.
It's unfortunate that in this model of
civilization it doesn't like there's any
other
way for us to learn other
than shit falling apart.
It's not like we can just look
at things and say, hey listen,
obviously we're doing this wrong and we're
going to have to figure out how to do
it right and one in the process of
figuring out how to do things right.
There's a lot of shit that's going to
go away and one of the things is people
who have billions of dollars,
you're not going to have billions
of dollars anymore because it's not,
your money is nonsense.
Okay?
Your money is basically a bunch of fucking
things that are in a bank somewhere.
And instead what we got to seek to do
is we've got to seek to have a resource
based economy,
a real resource based economy.
Then we've got to figure out who owns
these resources and how should these
resources really be distributed.
Sued should shump somebody be able to
camp in front of a diamond hole in the
earth and say, this is my fucking
hall. These are mine diamonds.
It's like Jeremy Frescoes long lost son.
Do you really own those diamonds?
Do you really own that
gold really owned that oil?
Well like who's who's to say
that these resources or yours,
should it not be that the resources
are what powers our economy?
Should it not be that the resources
instead or what powers our government and
that no one really owns them.
And then they're distributed to all the
people that claim the earth as their
home. And that sounds co Raisie
hippie nonsense socialist.
But the reality is you shouldn't be able
to fucking build a giant machine and
park at 10 miles off Louisiana in the
middle of the ocean and just suck billions
of dollars out of the earth and then
not give any of that back and then say,
this is ours.
We'd get all it was sucking all your,
you're draining the earth like a
giant mosquito bat vampire though.
Accountability when you put it that
not only know con accountability,
you're making money off the earth,
billions of dollars and you're making
it off the earth in international waters
or you're making it a national waters.
Are you making it in a bay or who
the fuck is, why is that yours?
Like what's yours? Cause you, you,
you got a contract to build this giant
sucking machine and where's that money
going? That's a lot of money. You can
control a lot of shit with that money.
You're making billions and billions and
billions of dollars off of oil money,
man. You know what kind of fucking
power you have to by lobbyists.
You know what kind of pal you have to
influence legislative law legislation.
You'd have a lot of fucking power.
Imagine if you get could zero out all
the bank accounts in the world. I look,
that seems white glove at the end.
When we had the financial crisis
in London in 2008 apparently RBS,
one of the banks have
Royal Bank of Scotland.
They were one day away from shutting
off the ATM machines and they were
seriously,
if you've ever thought of a food riot,
if you can think of people not being able
to touch their money. Oh my God. Really?
It was just, yeah. I mean, wow. Be some
man. Yeah, that would be some mayhem.
And you know, it's happened in little
small doses with the collapse of us in,
in America.
It's happened a bunch of,
there's a savings and loan collapse
that George Bush's son was involved in.
That was a huge scandal that,
you know,
cost people millions
and millions of dollars.
A lot of people's personal fortunes
were completely erased their life.
Vinnie Paz, the ends of the boxer, he
lost hundreds of thousands of dollars,
just gone. Disappeared. Sorry. We don't
have it anymore. You know, and that's,
that's what a part of this financial
bailout was in this, in this country.
The most recent one was trying to avoid
something like that happening with all
these big banks failing.
But at the end of the day,
if you're going to have a
society that is well designed,
you can't use an infrastructure that is
not well designed and maintain it. The,
the, the, the, the,
the structure that we have now is so
fucked up and corrupt and crazy and the
crux is starting to
show is a real big cats.
It's like having a giant building
made out of cardboard instead of just
acknowledging it.
You just throwing duct tape up everywhere.
It starts to separate you.
We've got to figure out a way for it to,
to be a society that makes sense and
the way that that's going to happen.
The only way that's going to happen
is you got to restructure finance.
You've got to restructure
what money really is.
You've got to restructure how
much money and how much, uh,
how much people get
paid to do certain jobs.
Because like most people
are fucking slaves.
They are just slaves with uh,
the Gov a loose Coloradan they're slaves
because of, and you know, by the way,
that's your choice.
You can not do that and you can,
I agree with all that. You know, you
can not be burdened by, you know,
a home and mortgage and finances and,
and you know,
a car payments and all that stuff. But
you know, what would really be better?
How about if you do actually work all day?
You get paid enough so that you could
save money and you don't have to worry
about shit.
You get paid enough so that you don't
have to worry about being constantly in
debt.
The idea of owning a house shouldn't be
out of someone's reach should be fairly
fucking acquirable.
That would make a lot more sense.
We just live in this really corrupt
system of loans and interest and just
nonsense number shuffling
and can tell you this.
I just don't know how we're going to
get there without blood everywhere.
You're right.
That's it.
I don't know either or
massive enlightenment and
that massive enlightenment.
Look.
Something happened for sure during the
60s and a lot of people attributed to
psychedelic drugs and the music change.
The culture change.
The society changed the
doors recently. Yeah, that's,
that's a big leap from buddy
Holly. Man, some big leaps.
Something happened that was a media form
back then. I was telling nick today,
how do you spread a message
without the Internet?
You do it over music and he listened to
Morris and his lyrics and you're like
changed kids. It changed kids.
That's one of the big things.
I guess the closest thing to Joe,
back in the day in the sixties and
seventies you know that black Sabbath's on
war pigs. Oh, rip van. Can you pull it up?
We had just a message through the,
through the music,
but you're always talking about that.
Get the kids to change first.
Is that your only everybody,
man.
Everybody that I talked to that
comes up to me and says, dude,
this podcast has changed my life.
He changed the way I look at things,
change the way I approached my life.
I realized that this,
this is not a permanent experience.
This is supposed to be a
ride and an enjoyable time,
a finite time that I can manage,
and if I just stick to a
certain amount of principles,
a certain series of principles,
rather go towards what you love,
actually do what you want to do,
be nice to people and have a
close knit circle of friends.
Love them as if you love yourself.
To true,
to really move in that direction is
possible for all of us. And that's,
that's the way you change the world,
the way it changed the world.
As you change the way people
look at things so that the,
nobody wants to be the the big content
charge because the big content charge
leaves a shit life. You
know these guys, look,
we live in a world where when kids get
crazy and they make a lot of noise in
there, they're fucking hard to deal with.
People give these kids antidepressants,
they give them Ritalin,
they give them, you know,
all kinds of different crazy shit.
Then when they get to be adults,
then they're even more fucked up and
sad and disconnected with their shitty
lives.
So then we give them antidepressants.
We give them more things to help them
get over this little mental hump.
Then there dick stops working.
What did they do? Well we come up,
we got to Cialis and Viagra and Levitra
and all sorts of pills that make your
dick hard. Well you know, we'll
dumb fucking this, this stuff.
This isn't helping me anymore.
Oh we got some other stuff that
you add on to your antidepressant.
You take this as well as that and this
is really going to put you over the top
and that's really gonna make you happy.
And we constantly keep looking for
some sort of a chemical fix for,
for, for depression and for, for the
lack of good feelings in this life.
And I think that there's certainly people
that have mental imbalances and they
are helped by pharmaceutical drugs,
by antidepressants.
But that not withstanding,
there is also people that are getting a
very bad signal from their life because
they're living a life that is
non harmonious. It's not fun,
it's not filled with love and joy.
They're not pursuing their true interests.
And everybody's interest
is fucking different.
And our natural state is to
be joyful and calm and happy.
And if you look at those,
all those stories of when people in
common to most indigenous cultures,
everyone's cool. Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It was also people that
love to be depressed. Okay.
And these people that revel in
depression take pride in depression.
Unfortunately, people that have criticized
me for talking about depression,
even in my own message board, some
fucking dummies wrote some stupid shit.
It was so sad. It's so poorly
thought out. Listening.
Does anybody get furious when you know,
you hear Joe talk about depression
because if you understand,
you don't think I've been
depressed before, stupid.
Everybody has been depressed.
People don't know that. You
have always a positive. Yeah.
Well that it took a long
time to get positive.
I've had a really awkward social moment,
really dark moments of terrible
feeling and that lasted months, months.
We will all have. Was there anything in
particular that got you through it? Um,
just that helps certainly. But then that
can be a source of even more depression.
Yeah. Yeah. Tell me about it. To a
hold of a bad one. What do you tell?
Because people are always
asking you for answers.
I know you don't want to be
the guy. You're like, I'm
not the guy trying to talk.
You tell you what I've learned
to help people. You know,
you can never tell people what to do,
but you can tell people what helped you,
you know?
And you could tell people what has aided
you and where you were going wrong and
how you saw it and corrected it.
So a big part of life is,
is got to be the way you
interact with human beings.
The happiness that you
derived from friendships,
the happiness that you derive
from doing things together from,
and also from creating things,
you know,
and the happiness that whether it's
creating carpentry or art or we are some
weird animal that constantly seeks to
use the imagination to make physical
things manifest themselves.
You know,
whether it's physical things in terms
of some things you can read online or
something that you could watch as
an a video podcast, whatever it is.
We have this massive amount
of satisfaction that we
get out of making things
cause we're some weird fucking be thing
where some weird insects and making a
hive. We're just making
this super complicated hive.
It's connected by billions and billions
of other little fucking weird pink
monkeys and we,
or brown monkeys and black monkeys and
yellow monkeys and we're all putting it
all together and we don't
know what it is. We don't, we,
we all are responsible for our own
little piece of this crazy machine called
culture and civilization.
We don't know what the fuck we're doing,
but clearly we're all working together
and some weird form and you can accept
that and you can, you can choose
to be depressed. You can choose to,
you can choose to live a,
an ineffective, inefficient,
non harmonious life because it's gonna
make your mother-in-law happy and,
and keep your marriage
together. Or you can, you know,
seek silence and calmness and truly
examine your situation and then slowly try
to turn that boat around.
Slowly tried to turn that battleship
towards where it needs to go.
I think Ari Shaffir said one time,
he said,
start with the people in your daily life.
He's like,
be nice to the waiter and be nice
to this person. And you know, it's,
it can be started really simple. That's
my shit. Drop, drop happiness bombs, Dan,
I'm gonna Start doing this.
You can do it. It helps life.
It puts forth more positive energy and
that sounds like Hippie dippie bullshit.
But it puts forth better feelings.
You feel better about the day.
And I think when you feel
better about the day you,
you think better about the
future, you think you, you,
you respond better to other people.
You set this ball in motion.
And when you make someone feel better
than they make someone else feel better,
like you know, if rscs me tip
people or be nice and then he says,
know I'm going to fucking do that too.
And then you hear about that and you say,
I'm going to do that too. And when, when
that happens and someone hearing this is,
that's how I'm going to do that is
just ripples and ripples of positive
reactions or can raise our collective
consciousness ultimately as much if not
more than anything that's
ever existed in human history.
The biggest bursts of change that I've
ever come forth in human history are
nothing compared to the reactions
that people are going to get to.
The free access of information and
content that the Internet has. The the,
the impact of the 60s ain't shit compared
to the impacts of the two thousands
and the 2000 tens and twenties there.
It's going to be log
rhythmically expanding.
We can't even wrap our heads around
where it's going and that's why the
government is panicking.
That's why they're building this
giant NSA spy fucking cabin in Utah,
one of the biggest, most expensive
projects that governments ever undertaken.
No money for Neil degrasse Tyson's
gigantic telescope to see the beginning of
time,
but they've got plenty of money to build
such a switch yourself holding to store
every fucking email you've ever written
to to take everybody's I a laptop
fucking camera and turn it on to watch
you beating off and store it and put it
in some fucking database somewhere and
you think that's a joke, but it's not.
It's true. Your fucking cell phone is
basically a giant gps tracking device.
That's all it is. It's scary.
You know, before I forget,
I just want to offer up London
real studios for you guys.
If you're ever in town to you know,
use as you as your studios if you want.
You guys want to like that would be dope.
If wherever in England for a UFC,
that's when I usually come over.
I mean,
obviously it would love
you guys on the show,
but if you ever want to just use
the studios and I'm wrecking,
you might be able get the queen
on your show or you guys got,
maybe you can get some crazy people that
are in England or in Europe or Terry or
one of those dudes. Is that a prince
or is that one of the ugly warts?
These are guys, he's a real
one. I never know who's, uh,
who's from Melinda's a trippy
place man is what does that show?
What's the movie again?
Harry Potter. Potter.
I never know if it's from Harry Potter
or real. He's real, but a red band shirt.
It says keep calm and carry on, on his, on
the front of his shirt. And that's like,
that pretty much says a lot about Britain,
you know. I mean, nick and I were,
were actually foreigners,
which is crazy.
And we started a show called London real,
I mean, I'm American, he's South African.
So what brought you guys to England?
I went for Bizzo and 10 years ago
financing. What'd you go for? Your,
I wanted to train Jujitsu.
I'm under it like someone high level so
instead of Roger. Right. Nice. So you,
when you moved to England for
hydro, Gracie, hydro, Roger,
some people call high some on the
show and he said either these guys,
the Brazilians Guy, they all
say Hodra. Yeah. You know,
he's a scary guy but
he's got the perfect Jujitsu body
to those long limbs. You know,
he's a big tall dude. I was surprised
when he came over. I was like,
I forgot how tall were you shocked when
he got knocked out by King Mo? Yeah,
I asked him about it on the show. Uh,
but I was surprised. But then again,
like you said, on any, on any
day and chemos got some power.
That's what's scary about wrestlers to,
if a wrestler, a develops knockout power,
the odds of you getting him down.
It's Kinda small. You know, it's real.
It's going to be hard to
get a wrestler down Jujitsu
guys versus wrestlers. Always a
weird sort of a, a combination.
Because if the Jujitsu guy can't get the
wrestler down and the rest of the guys
like a chocolate Dell guy, it's
bad for the Jujitsu Guy, you know?
But if the Jujitsu guy can
get the wrestler guy down,
a lot of times wrestlers have some bad
habits off their background. It's good.
Yeah, it's a, it's, it's,
it's interesting but that that king mo
fight shows you like a wrestler with some
serious power like King Mo.
That's a dangerous guy.
It's a dangerous guy to fight if you're
trying to take the fight to the ground.
It's weird. I asked Roger Wise in
London, cause he's a Brazilian guy,
you think it's the last place he'd want
to go right to the land of rain and they
say bad food. Lend it has some good
food, man. We just got to eat food.
I don't know where to go.
It was like an old bill Hicks joke.
You don't boil pizza. Hold
bit about money. Food being
bad. I'm like, you're crazy.
The Indian food, they're
sensational. We've had some great,
great Chinese food there.
Do you guys think that you got to London?
What does it feel like? Weird or, I love
it. I love London. I love the people.
I think they're there.
I think there's so much competitive
craziness in America and there's so much
arrogance in the American
attitude, which is, you know,
one of the things that built the
country sort of built, yeah. Made it,
it's fucking nutty as it is,
but it also makes it just exhausting.
I know the bit just
landing here from London,
it was like I was on Mars
and I walking around.
I'm seeing in Venice beach and there
is like a little bit of an aggression
levels. What's not done everywhere.
We were in North Carolina,
we were in Asheville this past
weekend, uh, and a Raleigh, Raleigh,
Friday in Asheville,
a Saturday.
And Asheville is a goddamn gem of a town.
It's just small town and I,
and everybody's walking on
the streets and you know,
we didn't even think about it.
Like,
where is this restaurant three blocks
up and to the right and we're all just
walking and everybody else is walking.
People walk everywhere.
And I'd be like that that's
missing in San Fran. In La,
it's completely missing in La.
Nobody walks anywhere you need to have
face to face contact the the tube in
London, which is the underground, you see
people face to face, you know, and you,
you,
you're constantly interacting with them,
seeing these crazy women wearing burkas
or some lady from Somalia and you're
smelling them and seeing them and
people just no more polite there too.
It's almost super polite. And
Mackie you say, sorry first.
I mean I have there 10 years now and
like the first thing he say, sorry,
it's really annoying when you're here.
Oh, it's not, it's beautiful. It's just,
you know, it's, it's setting
forth good intentions right away.
The theory that if you look at a place
that's America's such a huge landmass
that it's not ever that densely populated.
If you compare it to like Tokyo or
London where we were on this tiny little
island. And what happens is in places
like that where it's so densely populated,
people are forced to be,
they're forced to learn to be
able to live on top of each other.
And be nicer to each other because there's
nowhere out. There's no way to run.
I would agree with you.
Except for New York.
New York is filled with clients and the
stacked on top of these curl and shit
like chimpanzees. I lived there for a
few years and now it's too much for me.
It's um, it's not, it's, I hear
what you're saying, but no,
I think it has to do with why people came
here in the first place. The ripples,
the first ripples of intention of the
people that landed, they were crazy.
They were people who were so bold.
They got on a boat and sailed for months
across the fucking ocean is someplace,
they hadn't even seen a video
because video wasn't invented.
They were low CSTARS warning.
10 minute warning by London
I find is that there,
there are years behind the
technology curve. Like I know in La,
so many people have podcasts and maybe
in New York's probably lagged a couple of
years, but in London, I mean we totally
about London real and it's like,
it's a podcast and they'll be like,
it's a what?
There's just not a lot of people
there yet. That's interesting.
But I think that'll change.
Let me just talk.
You don't have access to computers and
an Internet connection microphones or you
could always buy them.
You know you guys will lead the way,
you know you'll be the ones and it's new.
That started out and at
first she showed people,
okay we have a show for an hour and
then they try to watch it like game of
Thrones for an hour. I was
like, oh it's not like that.
Well you know we have a lot of people
who do live shows here and I don't like
those. They do them in front of audiences.
Marin, Marin does that for an audience.
I just turn it off cause it
always feels like it's different.
Why are they trying to cater to the
audience and they're not talking to me.
They're faking on a ham it up
a little and you are aware.
I no doubt that 50,000 fucking whatever
it is and isn't in the audience.
You know,
I guys have done them with thousands
of people I know to Corolla does like
thousand seats. You know, it's crazy. I
just thought it was not my thing, man.
I don't think we thought it's
not the right sort of a vibe.
I think for podcasts
it's a different thing.
Some people are good Norton's great at
it, nor atlas. Really good at doing.
He like turns it up,
you know?
Do you think we should go live because
we don't have a live format but it's
effectively live cause we don't edit
in his one hour. But I was curious.
I mean you guys do have live as you
do whatever the fuck you want, man.
It doesn't matter. I said, I love it,
but I hate it. I hated it. You hate it.
You still hate it. No, no,
no. He's not saying in front
of an audience. He's saying,
Oh yeah, absolutely. Yeah, a lot.
Well, it's a pretty authentic,
everything we've said in this is,
it's been live for already been knows who,
how many fucking people, how many
people are listening to this from Brian?
Come on, you know, how
do you know the numbers?
How many people do watch your
show all together? We don't know.
Millions y'all. It's way. It's definitely
millions on Sirius radio right now.
We have 2100. Yeah. I mean like I'm just,
our Ustream page has 11
million, 454,000 views. Just,
just start page and way
more. Like, like he said,
there's only like 2000 people
watching at a time the most.
I think earlier it was probably close
to 3000 the most we've ever had.
Like maybe nine or 10,000 at once
watching it. Yeah. But the, the,
the real numbers or an audible downloads,
audio downloads, MP, three downloads,
right. That's where it gets crazy. Can
we drop our info to come check us out?
All right. We're um, the website's
a London real. Dot TV. Uh,
we're on Twitter at London Real TV and
you can always check out our youtube
channel,
which is London.
Real TV is a channel or just tied London
real into Google man. You'll find us.
And also guys that have a Jujitsu
site called Jujitsu Brotherhood.
That's all one word.
And I discussed my philosophies.
It's digital brother.com just talking
about my style of Jujitsu or everything's
free on there. You can go check it
out as well if you have a chance.
Beautiful guys, if anybody wants to start
a podcast in any city around the world,
if you got questions, you can
email a message. Just call us.
Wouldn't be happy to help.
I'd love to see more of these things.
You don't have to call it real. You
can call it whatever the fuck you want,
but they end and maybe in one year
from today you can be on Joe show.
Yeah, easily. Fuck man. I think
that's what it's all about, right?
I mean,
I think it's all about encouraging
other people to carry this on and a,
you guys are doing it the perfect way.
It's beautiful to watch.
I enjoyed watching your show.
I enjoyed listening to it,
listening to your conversations with
Graham Hancock and Simon and a a bunch of
other ones I've seen too.
It's awesome and I hope that you guys
spawn a million others and it'll just,
it continues on. Could have paid for
it. Right? Yeah. I think that really is,
it sounds so fucking corny and grandiose,
but I think that really is
the way to change the world.
The way to change the world is to let
people know how you've changed and then
that just, it branches out, it ripples.
It has this massive sort of
snowball effect and it just
grows and if there's any
way that we can improve our world,
it's improving the way the other people
around us see it and approach it.
You know the Ma,
this thing might be ridiculous.
It might be just one frame and an infinite
movie that goes on forever and that's
for a lot of people that get,
you know,
really sad about that and say,
well wow,
that's so pointless like what's happening?
But it's happening right now and
I'm enjoying the fuck out of it.
If it is happening right now,
if this is really one fucking step in an
infinite number of steps and it's just
a a life cycle that repeats itself again
and you're going to be a baby again in
50 years, guess what? I'm having
a great time fuck to do this.
And if I can figure out a way,
cause some amount of that,
transfer this energy into my next life,
I'll have that.
I'll have a great time in that life too.
You know,
I didn't always have a great time in this
life and I don't know what that's from.
I don't know. I don't, I don't know if
it's, I dunno if reincarnation is real.
I don't know if this is a onetime shot
and everything else is just your ego
trying to protect itself from
the inevitable doom of the, the,
the spirit which dies just like the
body does. I don't know. I don't know.
We're all gonna die one
day though, right? Maybe.
I'm not sure that either
we're all going to die.
I don't even know if that's real.
I'm not convinced this,
this whole thing might be a fucking
dream within a dream, within a dream.
But the playstation said wrapped up in
chocolate sauce and pumped into veins
through the, through a pot cookie that
Brian Red Band and you and your wearing.
No cookies, no cookies,
nick. But, uh, I think, uh,
what's made it fun for me is to have
these kinds of conversations. You know,
it's really made a made life
more enjoyable. And, uh,
I know that you guys are
positively influencing a lot
of people and I know, uh,
this show is, and all of our friends
are, and I think, uh, that's,
that's what's up you, I think
that's a, that's that's uh,
something that we've all locked into.
Most of us unexpectedly sorta
stumbled into it, but that's also,
I think that's the right way it's
supposed to go down. You know,
the universe has a plan for all
of this and uh, we a little,
little strange monkeys.
We follow the plan and if you're,
if you're resonating the right frequency,
if you have the right intent,
I think that plan turns out
the way this one's turning now.
I think it's good to helping everybody.
It's awesome.
London real bitches. Thanks
Jackson. What's up? Thanks so much.
So they can find you guys on
Twitter, London, real TV on Twitter.
Do you have individual Twitter accounts?
We just role as a team
and we do. We're like, we bicker
at each other to one of the,
actually gets married and starts having
kids and then you'll have suffered to
fucking problems that often.
Does she come in and they'll be like,
are you really going to podcast
with him again today? God,
you guys did one a couple of days
ago. No, I don't tolerate that.
Sun Strong and my household,
Tarzan, you Jane. That's
our role for life bitches.
They can't promote the death squad.
November 10th me,
Brendan Walsh and Tony Hinchcliffe
are coming to Columbus,
Ohio at the woodlands
tavern at on a brown paper,
tickets.com to search for a desk wide and
we're going to have a couple more days.
Anders, the special surprise guests that
I'm not allowed to say he's joining us.
Oh Shit.
Special surprise guest
and that is all you can get that
information to. also@desksquad.tv. Brian,
we'll have that up. We, yes.
Keep people keep asking me,
when are you going to put together
a website where you have all of the
information of everybody that's,
you know,
quote unquote involved in the desk squad,
we're going to do that.
It's just a matter of time. It's
just a matter of, like I said,
I have too much shit going on right now.
Brian is too much shit going on right
now or is somebody else doing it for us?
Vicky has got the best squad news
where it has all of our tour dates,
so that's nice as well. We'll say
look. Oh yeah, yeah, it has all of it.
Like Ari, Bert Kreischer, Brian
Cowen, Ra should fears fear road show.
That was,
well, yeah, it just, she hasn't updated
and then last week we got to have someone
to do. This is all when a, the studio
gets constructed and moving in place.
Brian and I just had some conversations
about it today and the regular weekly
shows that the ice house,
I talked to Bob today,
we had a little meeting he brought me in
and one of the things that Bob Fisher,
the owner of the Ice House wants to
do is have a weekly show here. Uh,
so I will be at the Ice House
every week that I am in town.
If I'm not in town.
I want to have a show here,
but most Wednesdays consider
it done this Wednesday.
So far it's Joey Diaz.
Duncan Trussell human probably.
Yeah, probably. Probably Brian. Uh,
I think Ian Edwards is coming to and I
think Ari should fear Irish affairs in
boom, Ra ship. You're just
texted me. He said I'm in. Boom.
That's how we roll. Look, it says
boom. It's, he really did say that.
That's what kind of fucking
psychic energy I'm putting forth.
Ladies and gentlemen. You see that color?
It's a bit, or you got your textile
boom. Okay. You dirty
bitches. He's in boom.
And if you want to get in one of those
super sweet desk squad, TV, TV, TV,
shirts, what's a TV shirt,
desk squad t shirts,
the ones that I saw everywhere
in North Carolina this weekend.
Holler at your boy. They're
available. A death squad.tv.
And again, those go directly to
support Brian's podcast network.
So if you liked the icehouse chronicles
and all those other cool podcasts and
Kevin Pereira who will be starting
tomorrow, Thursday. I'm sorry,
I missed the Thursday. So, um, that
is uh, that's, that's what's up.
Um, this week we have, tomorrow we
have Dunkin motherfucking Trussell.
We joined the podcast and then on
Thursday we have amber Lyon who is the CNN
reporter who was a, he, they,
they censored her man. And uh,
it's going to be, this is going
to be really fascinating stuff.
This is going to blow your mind because I,
I've been listening to several interviews
of her that are already available
online and this is a one courageous
woman. And uh, this is, uh,
this is going to be really,
really fascinating.
Look into the world of
big time journalism.
You dirty bitches. All right, thanks
to [inaudible] dot com go there.
Get yourself some Alpha
brain son. They say, hey man,
what is neural transmitters do? I say,
they make you awesome. That's all I know.
All the other stuff is Mumbo jumbo and
my eyes are going and I can't even read
the small print without eyeglasses,
but go to use the code name Rogan.
Yes.
Become an ant,
a use a code name Brogan and you will
save 10% off any and all orders of
supplements including hemp force,
the most delicious hemp protein
available known to man motherfucker.
It's gotten Maka in it,
which is good for your penis.
And it's also got raw cocoa in it,
which is an excellent antioxidant.
So, uh, that's the schedule for this week.
New podcast studio is in
construction right now.
We go live with the Internet this Friday.
So a within a week we'll start
doing some shows from there,
but we will never abandon the ice house.
Ladies and gentlemen, this is our home.
We love you. You love us. We are one,
all of us together in this crazy fucked
up soup of humanity that might just be a
dream. See You tomorrow. Freaks.